he's on a roll morning else I something
is enough to win here okay H for now
that was not a good mission before the
terrible move the pawn can't take is
this Chuck Wow
so frustrated I just resigned Anish
[Music]
well you know these guys are taking it
seriously Robert when they've both been
logged on to chest comm for more than an
hour and both participated in practice
games this morning here you can see
we've been following a zero chess with 3
s's shock rearmament yards new account
he's getting set to take on a niche giri
in a match that has had most people just
on the edge of their seat hotly
anticipating what might go down between
these two and so I'm gonna ask you first
how accurate do you think our
predictions are do you believe shock we
are to be the favorite in this match and
what do you expect to go down here today
that mom Jeff would be the favorite but
after watching some of his bullet games
here on chess calm server I'm not so
sure granted those boo game did not have
increment so that's a big difference
that one second increment really is a
huge difference between then just one oh
but I think it's a pretty big toss a
buzz point Giri has proven very strong
on the server
he's an epic match with Wesley so and
then there was of course his demolition
of the qualifier opened when he didn't
need to qualify but he chose to do so
and when the biggest prize so he's been
very impressive and I think he has very
good chances well he it was active on
Twitter this morning saying he knows
he's going up against one of the wisest
men in chess although a fun a fun play
on the the recent cover of new and chess
magazine as anybody who subscribes to
one of the best chess magazines in the
world will definitely say that cease
chakra are gracing their cover he's got
to be stronger better faster wiser in
order to take down shock today and
that's that's what a niche is is
apparently my my screen isn't isn't
quite showing but that's what Anisha is
is knowing he needs to be today but we
see he is sitting down and ready we're
as shocked we are apparently just
stepped away to take a quick break so to
remind everybody of the of the format
and of what is going down here real
quick we will we will do that the the
stats as you see there will keep you
updated on how those predictions look
throughout the day but of course this
matchup here is the
the last first-round matchup in this
year speechless championship the winner
of today's event will go on to face
Levon Aronian and for those of you
who've asked what will the schedule be
in the second round we will be releasing
that as soon as possible working with
all the players they have a very busy
month coming up between the Olympian or
my partner will be a coach of the US
women's team and a number of other
events it's it's pretty tough to be a
chess organizer scheduling dates these
days I'm not going to lie but the the
players are competing for a lot in
prizes but also the chance to move on
for a vegetable speech chess
championship glory and of course we also
know that the format will be the same as
you've already seen and every other
first-run matchup this being our eighth
and final one so Robert we'll get into
how we see the second round breaking
down I'm already getting excited about
that but really no reason to look ahead
of what's going down today because both
players were ready we're ready I know
your mom is ready because she texted me
earlier and she again said Danny thanks
for thanks for calling him Bobby again
despite his wishes you and I are on the
same page and I said thank you mrs. Hess
for supporting me and everything I do
and especially with your son Bobby here
so so your mom and I are ready you're
ready the whole match is ready Anisha is
ready shox ready let's do this thing
you know I I just want to say how wrong
you are
and then my mom I hope she's listening
right now and just met but uh I'm ready
for the game your way so we can stop
talking about this yeah but you know
wondering whether Samara is about to
crawl out of chakra our mama garbs video
from the ring just here's the deal
everybody as long as you share this
chess broadcast with somebody in seven
days Samara will not come after you so
that's your job to help chess go viral
share this broadcast in seven days in
Samara will not crawl out of Shox camera
and come after you but the games are on
the chess is ready yep and we see that
mom and Jeremy ops four appear to the
fence which is not typically seen at the
highest levels in classical chess where
these two players meet most
but of course is a very actually good
opening in speed chess and the reason
why is because you can't rely on your
opening theory from the white side and
because at you know especially the
highest levels playing with the white
pieces gives you a big advantage
statistically in white just does very
well that kind of kicking your opponent
out of opening theory is generally
speaking a pretty good thing in my
estimation so so far very normal black
tries to play e5 right now you can't do
so because I wouldn't hang upon and
Bishop d3 of course is useful to protect
that pawn on e4 and so far I think
Anisha is the one more comfortable based
on time management and the fact that
white is objectively slightly better in
these opening stages but I like mom
again I like mom and Gary's choice I
think all is well for him thus far he is
gonna try to get a 5 in from blacks
point of view and try to get more space
in the center but Gary can sort of
ignore any Castle queenside yeah it's
interesting for you to say that the the
Pierce is a weapon you think is a good
one in rapid and blitz and and you
talked about some of the reasons for
that the flexibility but Gary going for
a more almost a hybrid here between a
classical development in the two Knights
normally you might see a pawn chain here
when white is going for this sort of
early and aggressive Yugoslav style
attack so what is what is White's
playing here when the knight has
replaced the pawn on f3 which normally
helps she for and of course would
prevent this whole blockade on the light
squares how is Gary gonna justify this
attack against the Pirates is he
punching h5 through and sac in the
exchange or what is your what is your
thought about about where this middle
game is headed yeah I mean you would
love to play h5 of course but for now at
least it looks like black as well
covering that side and a tribe even if
it loses a pawn is typically a worldly
sacrifice because you open up the edge
file for your rook that said in this
current position after h5 I wondered if
black can get away with simply taking it
with him like this ship takes h5 very
risky of course because once this Knight
moves away from f3 white can throw an f3
in G for himself so here comes a he is
going for it
I'm ready to sacrifice a pawn and
typically this is I mean as someone
who's you know been checkmated on both
sides of this type of positions more
times than I'm comfortable talking about
outside of therapy
I can say that white does often
eventually get compensation for the open
H file the question is really is blacken
to get enough counter plate to prevent
white from being fully focused on the
the kingside because as you said even
with an extra pawn eventually this night
will move white will get the pawn storm
going and fishers dream on the h-file of
sack sack mate will still be a threat so
so what is black gonna do now to try to
play on the queenside and try to get
counter play to prevent Geary from just
focusing solely on the kingside yeah
it's really tough I don't see the
counter play right here on the queenside
coming quick enough because the threat
is very simple h6 g6 Bishop g7 Queen h6
and in some water and the reason why if
I was okay for now is because let's just
look Bishop on Jay's g6
you take what the f pawn it was mistake
what the H pawn you're getting
checkmated right away but you take what
the F pawn and say that okay I know you
will take me on g7 try to put your queen
on h6 check but the end of the day I'll
put my queen on e7 and or my rook on f7
and defend my seventh rank and that way
the h7 pawn is not actually going to be
lost and so I think this is so far okay
for black I mean you're not luckily lost
yet and I would if I'm white I'm trying
to wait before taking on g6 because you
know I'm going with the hope that I
actually don't have to do it in the near
future so I don't give black a resource
with Brooke f8 to f7 protecting the
seventh right good like I just delay
that for as long as possible that's
that's the optimal strategy for wiped I
don't know
how much longer you really can because
at a certain moment I could take with
the knight mh5 as well and then my queen
covers the g5 swears he doesn't see
anybody yeah I was gonna say he's going
for can I just say you can talk while I
highlight all day like you talk I
highlight that's our relationship I like
it you you are the artist speaking those
relationships I want to give a big shout
out to everybody in the twitch chat we
have a personal relationship with all of
you shout out to the one and only chess
Bay here all of our moderators thank you
so much thanks for leading the way Bey
and all the mods for helping she's let
it be known that she's rooting for Geary
let us know who you're rooting for you
can spam their fat heads if you're a sub
just go ahead and spam it let us know if
you're rooting for the shock or the
Geary but thanks to everybody who's
there everybody in the chess TV chat as
well
I see you baby we got diamond remember
zai zai we got gold member John HS just
thanks to everyone for being here
supporting us our relationship continues
and we don't need therapy for us so
Robert and I do but you and I don't so
alright yeah so I mean look at this play
though energetic play by black right
just say okay I'm gonna just eliminate
some of the pieces and that makes the
attack seem less wrong I'm not sure if
it actually is less strong but at least
appearances my biggest issue with blacks
approaches that if white makes this
trade plays f3 so that you have the
legal right to castle right can't castle
through check and then oh okay I was
gonna say and guess castles long I was
pointing out that at some point the D
file and maybe even the d6 pawn is the
issue but maybe that's why he Castle
dried away instead of trading right
didn't want to remove that weakness from
d6 and instead is willing to sacrifice
f3 to get the King out of the center
right away right and I think people be
like well what I'm just Knight takes f3
pawn takes f3 Bishop f3 I'm hitting two
rooks on my bishop I'm winning a pawn
and now I'm gonna wouldn't let you know
what it is I think it's I think it's
Queen h6 and E 5 right absolutely
but the question is is that actually
forceful enough because okay Queen h6 so
you can move your king you've couple off
king f7 is not out of the question just
trying to run away from your attack and
you know that does look scary I'm not
gonna deny that of course but perhaps
kf7 works because King F survived well
you might want to take my knife you know
I like refi because if you okay if you
take I even have Bishop c4 check if I'm
really into getting the Queen back or
Bishop takes g6 check right with mine
own f3 I would have taken with a knight
back on e5 oh no no I've taken on f3 in
my line okay I took on have three Bishop
takes then Queen h6 check your moves and
I'm punching II thought through got it
now we're in the same page you were
working through our relationship issues
we weren't so you know what that's what
she kept telling us in therapy she said
it's communication guys that's your only
issue communication this looks very
scary now I like my King on f7 for this
line because that way I could through
said honey Geary was a draw master by
the way cuz this is some crazy
aggressive chess who said Murray doesn't
know how to attack I never said it
in fact I was given the stat beforehand
but my client that in there
classical chess games they both have won
three games and then they've gone seven
so that's almost a 50% decisive rate in
their games between these two players
and to give credit to shock sometimes he
makes you like get a decisive result
because he's in the super aggressive
player himself but Giri so far so good
for him I don't know how black defends
this because they take on g6 of course
Queen takes g6 check and then at the
cage one was mates Bishop f3 is a good
move not only does it save the bishop
but it takes away the h1 square for the
room rook g1 here at the very least is
worrying me because I'm gonna move my
bishop away but you know rook do you
what do you we need to stop me from your
rook John feels feel so good I want to
put the rook on that spot let's do it
bring the rook over if you like I can
also take up six but that just feels
feels real good
Oh taking out of six can't be bad either
I think it's got to be what he's
calculating but I think at this point
Geary is choosing between flavors first
flavor flav reference we are not even 10
minutes in somebody just want to prop at
White's gonna win this game
and Geary is setting the tone as you
said you've got a really aggressive
player one who's known for his
aggressive attacking chess and in mom a
jar of and but Gary's uh and I told you
that I really well okay I know off the
record how much and he really wanted to
win last year's match enough okay that
should be an obvious he barely lost to
Wesley so but I mean like really I think
more people didn't appreciate it and I
know he was excited to do to throw down
here so just having that year of defeat
in his mouth whereas shock maybe you
know has a lot going his way right now
makes me feel like of the two players
gary has got to be the more motivated
one to bring it today yeah and actually
you know if they'll say a lot you make a
great point and look at mom Jarvis
sidestepping the G file saying my king I
made shape well unless your bishop moves
and your Queen g7 check and one turn
Ashley Bishop e4 here should be quite
good then he said I was just trying to
make a point that you know you want like
Queen g7 check because after Queen takes
g7 politics g7 checked you win the rook
on f8 which means that Bishop e4 is just
very strong
but in the point I was gonna make her
otherwise I think you you make a great
one that being motivated is huge you
know an event like this because if these
players are of similar strengths
generally speaking and having that kind
of motivation that firepower will come
in handy as ammunition and we set up a
new day yesterday yep
Kuryakin of course wanted to win but
Duda is new to this experience being top
level chess and queen g7 check goes up a
piece and here's the end of the game but
yeah you know we start with Duda
yesterday and we'll see it with a niche
today where niche hasn't really been
playing that much and he has not been
playing that many classical tournaments
and so you know perhaps he's using this
as a sort of preparation for the
Olympiad in addition just wanting to win
speeches championship overall know and I
think he considers himself an underrated
rapping and blitz player and was nice to
be said just genuinely pretty frustrated
that it didn't go his way versus so but
either way two passes the past in the
present he's up a game over ma'bud
Gaurav and spending a lot of time with
these players before the the match they
were both super professional helping us
get all set up I know that they're both
happy that their sound was muted because
both asked in different ways to make
sure that if they happen to be upset
with a move they might play and they did
maybe use a certain type of word or
explicit ofnot saying that would ever
happen right would it be heard by the
fans and I gave them permission to
express themselves freely yep and you
know mommy urbex kind of left after that
defeat yeah not that any was laughing at
himself just wow I really didn't up to a
good game there and he certainly did not
and here he is going for the set up
where okay what currently has an
isolated pawn giri is not super afraid
of that because if you take out c6 you
helped me fix my pawn structure and if
you don't take on c6 and move backwards
black's pieces are actually very
free-flowing here and and the knight on
c6 is well placed the bishop on e6 all
black pieces look pretty good now watch
out for one's knight moves from d4 and
then I had enough six is now under
direct threat right so the big problem
for for white is after Knight takes c6
pawn takes he says Bishop takes f6 well
I can get away with just Queen takes b5
and I take that Bishop instead of the
one f6 oh I don't calm
- my king safety this is why this
retreat is played I just simply Bishop
to d3 and from blacks point of view I
move like Bishop e5 is certainly not out
of the question
Knight takes c6 would be met by Bishop
takes B - yep and it's a Queen d2 played
and that now note that you're not
winning a pawn Knight takes d4 pawn
takes d4 Bishop takes d4 Bishop takes
you for Queen takes before well if I'm
getting being greedy it looks good
except Bishop takes h7 check opens up
that discovery so that's something that
I'm like this amazing game where all I'm
doing is trying to instruct on
everything you say in the analysis board
to keep going yeah and so it's um it's
defended through tactics and that's just
something that I think a lot of players
overlooked especially less experienced
players they think oh I need to put a
piece protecting my piece they would
have played move like bishop from d3 to
e2 or c2 last move you know to protect
it but the reason what Bishop d3 was
played in the first place is
understanding of the pawn before was
defended via tactics still the pawn de
forests are protected 293 allows
development your black is perfectly fine
here though you both have isolated pawns
the knight on c3 it does attack the pawn
on d5 that pawn is about to be very well
defending what's a bishop moves to c6
and the reason why you put is Bishop on
d7 rather than e6
is at least from d7 there you're spying
on both sides of the board I was gonna
say what it is has got to be this
holding the a Foursquare preventing
things like 94 95 right 100% it covers a
four covers b5 so it doesn't give white
any play on that side of the board and
the bishop on e6 would be really be
servicing like a poet or just be
protecting the pawn d5 and doing nothing
more so that pawns well defended with
the name f6 and this is just as equal as
they come so I would not be surprised if
they drawers offered soon but at the
same time white is doing well here like
you know 91 to e3 to f5 that is the good
thing you're having a slightly more
flexible knight in a position like this
I can come in very handy and I think if
93 Bishop F formerly played trying to do
a little bit of cattle Blanca here
saying I'm getting into the endgame we
give this Bishop on b2 that can't do
anything and my knight will just post
itself on e4 yep and say I dare you to
try to kick the lightzord bishops are
gone right efore becomes a huge target
doing a kappa blanc on the board may be
about to do a dab on screen we see on
each key
bobbing his head makes me remember that
remember last year he was he was quite
the fan of whatever music he was
listening to and there he goes again
he's a letting it be night what do you
think is this in the house we should ask
him it's definitely gonna be on the
agenda for after afterwards but but he
seems relaxed I would be too if I won
the first game and seemed to be on route
to holding holding with the black pieces
yep
and I mean there's no issue here at all
right now and just now the Queen's are
traded if you what black really wants to
do is take on e3 and trade off his
light-square bishop so if you removed
those lights core bishops from the board
Bishop takes c3 5.94 and black is
dominating the position because the dark
squared bishop for white can't attack
anything there's nothing to poke and
prod at the night as it can move from
color to color it had always the
advantage over bishops in many an
endgame because of that when when
there's not pawns in the opposite sides
of the board so that's a very important
thing is thanks to the chess TV chat for
complimenting my arrows you're getting
compliments that says I have to give TMS
credit for being a great analyser
learning a lot from his commentary
diamond member Pino 724 and Johnny HSS
yep and Danny draw arrows really well to
Danny you are the bat would rather have
nobody with me and drawing the air so
and you know this move age file just
standing space Knight takes d5 is to
move that what really wants to be light
but unfortunately on black recaptures on
d5 it protects that bishop on at four so
Bishop h6 just to you know kind of
really illustrate the point
the bishop DC special h6 would have been
bad because then Knight takes d5 comes
into play and your Bishop on h6 is on
free so he just backs it up
not like a Tonka truck before you say I
was gonna say never mind long as you
don't call me Big Daddy when you back
that thing up Robert we're alright
Bishop comes back to f4 again
highlighting your point there is no lets
out for that see why said g4 pawned fall
though key for g4 defended for now g4 g
for the G fourth is with you the chief
or is with you
so many references to the g4 squared
that that come up often but all right
seriously no this has been a pretty
high-quality chest from Geary so far
after winning the first game feels like
he's holding with ease right now if
anyone I mean I don't know who who do
you see as having the edge in his
endgame I guess I'm looking at the
bishop on it for being well posted d5
being defended it's hard for me to be
afraid as black in this position but are
there some outside many chances for
either player that grandmasters like you
can see but lowly international masters
like me can clearly not firstly you're
more than capable of analyzing this
position Danny I don't want you to be
down on yourself but realistically I
think it's pollution is completely level
there are no infiltration point if you
want to if you're white you're just
saying okay I want to trade pieces and
get this over with but look at a niche
playing on he understands it if I trade
on that d2 I trade off the bishop that's
not doing too much and yeah again the
ideal situation would be to somehow
trade off both bishops for black and
leave a knight against an enemy might
squirt it sorry dark-squared bishop
before white and here it doesn't really
matter because there's nowhere to
infiltrate for look at all the squares
and board you know when you think about
chess you think try to envision a future
on the board that you know provides you
with the best chance as possible now
here actually white is gaming some steam
because a four then maybe I have five
and the kingís are trying to walk up the
board and from black you say well the
King is a little bit more limited just
as I see the board as it currently
stands and so d4 is very difficult for
black to attack d5 this bishop can
reroute so from c2 over through d1 to f3
it's always a possibility you move f5 is
certainly an option as well for white so
I think in the last couple of moves
white is the one who's made some
progress whereas black is the one who is
now a little bit on the back foot King
f3 to g4 place itself and once that King
comes in g4 well if I come Dave Eiland
away right all the way mate bring it in
and if six pawn is become a target so
this is definitely improving for momager
I think moments of these are important
not because he's going to win this game
I still think this game should and will
be a draw but the reason why if
sometimes you get these moments
very magnus carlsen sort of thing where
you just start pressing your opponent
and you show them your force yep you say
I am a superior player in this type of
position and you're gonna be on your
back foot trying to defend for the rest
of the game black is totally fine your
Giri is nothing's wrong but when you
just see the trends of the duration
sudden that Giri looked like he's better
and now he looks worse that's
uncomfortable as a chess player well
it's also true that he's you're setting
the tone for the match right that's what
makes World Championship matches and
matches like this different in the sense
that you're getting a lot of games
against the same person you're not
valuing your energy levels based on the
whole tournament and okay if the game is
a draw these guys have ten eleven more
games to play in a tournament like Wieck
and Z maybe maybe they they allow the
peaceful result but here like you said
you're setting a psychological message
as much as you are a chess message right
pushing on in a position just to remind
them that hey if you feel like you have
an edge you're gonna you're gonna grind
it out and push and the only
counter-argument to that is that so far
of the two players shock has seemed to
be a little bit slower than uh neish and
you know given the time the longer you
do that in blitz it's a little bit
different than you know maybe sending a
message in a world championship match
trying to make your opponent struggle
psychologically in defense don't get
yourself under too much time pressure
here because because then that could
backfire
yeah the position is not so dry there's
no went too far down this road and all
the sudden ease down twenty seconds now
Anish you know look at these pawns over
here on B three and a four and I've got
myself a light square bishop with with
an eye on the prize so there's I mean
black has some chances here too in fact
if I have why can't I get slightly sure
hello Bueller Bueller here comes and you
know Bishop d1 now I'm just allowed
there should be one more oh he takes it
first which oh maybe even better
yep and Gary just gave a little bit of a
shrug and singing along to whatever
Taylor Swift album he's got playing on
repeat come on I was an event I got them
just wants to know if we knew what they
were listening to and chess pace said
let's just hope they're not listening to
Danny Touche
agreed with that no but we don't know
what the players will listen to I know
it's shock the neither of them are
hearing us that's part of the rules and
we walk them through how not to
hear us but keep their computer sound on
if that is what they want to do so but
we'll ask them afterwards don't worry
fans well here is gonna win this one
isn't go king d6 we should be three
Bishop c4 and then pushed b5 and I'm
gonna pass a point that's the executive
meeting strategy he's uh interesting
that he oh he's he triangulating them
some look at that that is the best
was tickle you get to that was going
over there you know what kind of tickle
that is all the bishops coming to e8
look at him God dude this is this is
some high quality technique take note as
far as how you relocate put the bishop
on d7 as what he's gonna do eventually
oh no I thought he would just target
both pawns and then get the King in but
this works doing yes nodding his head he
knows he's on a roll he's definitely an
event head yeah well I don't know what
he's listening to but he's definitely on
a roll we already have had by the way a
donation to the prize phone I guess we
forgot to mention that earlier so I'll
just do so now give a shout out already
to user who was it here I was told user
hb4 three has already donate here comes
liquid egg product with another donation
remember it goes directly to the players
in fact we just launched a commemorative
limited time only speech Chess
Championship mugs in our merch store
here right below the twitch player so if
you want a speech Chess Championship mug
any mugs purchased today go directly to
the prize fund as well so today if you
decide you know what I need me that mug
and you want to make sure you support
the players go ahead and get one and
it'll go directly to the prize fun but
alright thanks everybody for being here
all nearly 2000 of you the chess rages
on and Geary Geary showing that these
these stats as we said right well stats
direction yeah but didn't the pre-match
stats say that mom and jars over maybe
showing that these stats maybe maybe
weren't uh maybe weren't all that at all
that they were supposed to be yeah I
agree
and here we have mom and jharvard the
black side of an open Spanish and
firstly mama jar has been amazing from
the book from all both sides they open
Spanish but I've been very impressed
with his
in recent months in the miss structures
and what he's done here in this
particular setup is you know he gives
himself a an awkward looking pawn on d5
and the problem is that this bishop on
e6 is stuff defending we mentioned them
this sort of earlier with passive Bishop
versus a more active piece if you take
on b3 once white captures back the whole
points playing against the C pawn so if
I can stop you from playing c7 to c5
I could put a rook on c1 and just go
after your C pawn what is going on with
this ugly Poncho's gonna say how how did
this happen I there's a series of trades
there that just made me want to vomit
because look at this yeah but I like I
like Thwaites Knight a lot you know I I
don't know I mean I maybe I'm biased you
know to an active horsie but you know
can i play the rook - z6r okay v also so
a Bishop b3 now is just gonna play rook
to a-1 it should be three I've broken
one or rook d6 I like rook d6 better
yeah now the c5 pawns of target a6 is a
target it's one of those positions
showing the power of a night against a
bishop because I guess you go c4 from
black you've defeated your pawn and your
Bishop at the same time but then your
Bishop is just doing absolutely nothing
that sort of stuff that we talked about
that right that an active night can
often be just as good as a bishop even
when there's pawns on both sides of the
board in an open Center yep and h6 is a
very useful move you just want to make
sure that you'll never get checkmate on
the back rank your King can go to h7 and
you know okay
each floor plate so that King h7 you'll
never get out to g6 if I play age five
but if white does play h5 which has not
done but if that was a possibility
black would threatened in some mode
bishop d1 hitting that pawn age five
we've seen these bishops start roaming
around the board so I don't know if I
were then that afraid of white trying to
play each raise five that said the big
problem for black is let's say you go
rookie six in 466
white is happy to just go ahead and play
on 66 and get it passed on but the D H
Square covered by the knight on c6 so
it's a not an easy endgame here
for Mama Jarrah because well as king
just come in f4 for white and black it
really means to find some sort of
activity to set up a defense of resource
I would say Bishop c4 to b5 and just try
to kick this night out okay start to the
brook c8 and if rook takes d5 played
Bishop a few notes very similar concept
I need this night but still funky here's
Gary playing for two results right he's
over there more than a minute up on the
clock even lines like okay let's say we
go with this rook takes e5 Bishop a4 I
bring the King and f4 best-case scenario
you trade into a rook ending where wipe
really is in no danger of losing with
the active King yep
and here he goes he's gonna allow it the
question is now does he immediately
bring up the King does he see six as a
possibility I would guess they're
bringing the King up that one risk of
that as if we did get a big old trade on
c6 there may be something like rook b8
trading a 4b so that blacks rook can get
active that might be the fastest route
to a draw if your mama Gaurav so maybe
Gary thinking twice before he just
brings his King up and leaves the g2
pond behind from that eventual Rotom b2
but Gary has been phenomenal on the
claws so I mean no seriously he's played
much faster and we know that zero chest
you can just look up the username on
chest comm to see what we're talking
about spend some time playing bullet
before the match today maybe he kind of
woke up and said you know I'm not
feeling as sharpen this online time
controls I need to be and and here here
he has been down on the clock most at
most the day so all right likely this is
still a peaceful result I think king of
four rook to the second ring can be met
by g3 but still I would guess what best
play black shouldn't lose this yeah
black should not lose this game and the
reason why is because even if white
plays it a magic plays east six and all
right well now e6 is not gonna happen
but you take never taken on e4 you got
rooked a4 check and lose d yes so he
plays g3 first but let's say evens the
thing is even if he wins this pawn right
it's it's still not the ideal type of
structure you would you would want if
you're if you're winning and a rook a
pawn up rook ending but but okay I mean
there's always there's always chances in
blitz to win
all types of equal endings so or we just
saw it happened didn't yummy so I
definitely agree with that king of five
now he's now he'll take the pawn play a
little tickle go back to f5 keep threats
of of you know if black ever leaves the
seventh ranked everyone the brook will
go there check kick the King back and
likely try to punch a six through
something like this is White's winning
idea even if there isn't an exact way to
do it just yet
yeah you know you can give the check on
b7 the king will come back to the eighth
rank and for white there's no clear path
forward because e six for y it's hard to
punch through you you really want to
play that but even if you do in some of
those variation will just come back
right give it a shot yeah so he'll take
here and then go back and then the
question is what's next yeah if King up
five rook a three it's perfectly
reasonable yeah I just don't see if you
can we can forward it seems like this is
just fizzle out okay King f3 can be
played then why can't like efore then
King up four and try to slowly push
forward but there's only so far you can
yellow and the EE pawns don't help your
case at all well Gary's gonna do his
best to kind of push on his advantage
right now where he's got two games up on
the clock I mean two games up on the
scoreboard knows that the shock is sort
of reeling here to stop the bleeding
so if I was him I would I would do the
psychological thing we talked about
mamakara trying to do last game even
though would eventually backfired I
would push this game out as long as I
could and you know make make put your
opponent in a position where they're
comfortable being worse right make him
play a position where he's worse and can
only draw for as long as you can just
for those for those reasons so you know
Danny we've talked a lot about mat
strategy right and if Geary was paying
attention
he might have seen mommy hurts earlier
bullet games and said I shouldn't be
afraid in the board games although to
make her sudden death is much different
than bullet with increment but yes I
agree with you uh-huh
yeah completely agree but if Geary feels
comfortable enough in the bullet portion
he certainly feels comfortable in the
five-minute he should feel comfortable
three-minute then maybe he doesn't mind
prolonging these games just to keep that
you know the mass clock ticking you'll
get and say well two-game lead is you
know people make jokes are geared
drawing all the time but on a serious
matter it's extremely hard to beat the
guy no I mean no I mean whether you like
that it ends peacefully or not he is a
he is a rock right and if you combine
that with with good form right meaning
he's you know he's in form he's seeing
tactics well he's there's a reason why a
lot of people have seen him as since he
was very young as a potential you know
world championship candidate that being
a nice giri so yeah and he always said
how he had a winning record against
Carlson and okay he'd won one game or
call and drawn every other game right
and now he's lost he's down two games
two wins for Carlson - one for Geary but
it just shows you know this guy's very
difficult to meet and yeah yeah mom Jeff
is of course not an easy flair to beat
either but I think he's more up and down
he will go in crazy awesome tournaments
ooh he 6 can play f6 for black and well
actually f6 might be met but if I rookie
she's insane he's got check and if you
go to the 8th ranked I'm getting in with
main threats sacrificing the G pawn not
to say it's winning but certainly it's
the last try right when you when you
have fing up 65 is made for an important
okay let's let's make sure that we we
drop the mate like it's hot there we go
oh wait five is made for black 277 there
a five Oh where's the maker's King g5
but then you woulda lost g3 so yeah both
sides and we're looking at the e5 square
yeah and now a problem for white is rook
g7 if I ripped before check could not
leave like a 45 you've given the
fourth-ranked for a check and everyone
can go over the chief attacking and and
protecting yeah so it let's let's do
some calculation here rook g7 rook
before check King g5 rook g4 check King
f6 okay plays rookie sevens going
straight for the e pawn that's probably
just superior and one of the key ideas
everyone is that a black at play King D
5 you go back to d7 with check and then
to d6 likely making sure you win the e6
pawn so okay yeah this is a this is the
exact type of endgame on one of the
start calculating because now White has
the more easily advance will pass pawn
right up on
five can be pushed very quickly much a
meet yeah so rook G sinking you're up
I'm thinking Ritchie 72 highlighted that
but not sure if he'll go for it you
could also play King e6 in this exact
position if you're if you're thinking
you don't want checks there's no there's
no check by the rook but my guess is you
move the rook and as quickly as you can
try to just create the most brute force
version of advancing the e pawn forward
one advantage of keeping the rook on the
long side though with rock a7 would be
that then on e6 e7 your route can
actually help and sometimes more
effective ways okay he decides to go
Brooke h7 I like that because now when
he takes on g6 rook takes h5 not only
wins us the pond right but it also
protects the e5 pawn you're looking to
which one this is so rook f4 check King
g6 King d6 the king is close enough to
the h1 that's the good news for Mom jar
of key five wasn't 96 yeah that was a
key moment that King e5 didn't work as a
Brooke at five if King me five worked
this game was over white one listen now
I think I think now Hawk will hold the
draw yes because very importantly the
king is close to the H pawn for black
here so the H four pawns already hanging
so he took to protect it and after King
e6 okay poor and King goes back to h5
and the way to win this for y is if
you're you've cut the King off many yeah
the king let me cut off typically to the
opposite bishops file if you're if
you're into technical rook endings
keeping score at home this is this is
not even close as far as white having
winning chances the King is way too
close yeah mama Jarvis camera still
freaking me out by the way Samora will
be coming out of that thing any moment
and make sure you share this video in
the next seven days or the ring will get
you whatever happened to all the sequels
there right talk about a franchise that
just should have stayed at one movie
sometimes you can ruin the fear of a of
a bad guy in a horror film by just
overdoing it
you know hashtag Jamie Lee Curtis knows
that so
anyway well no seriously this is a very
nice little finish there by Gary self
stalemate yeah it looks like a mouse lip
but it's for the
as the kids would say the stalemate is
lit the chat is lit what no kids don't
say that please stop please none please
stop yeah okay we moved back to the
house where shout out we've already
gotten 20 bucks down into the prize fund
mm starts the day if anyone wants to be
a part of it go ahead and do it
buy some merch today all merch goes
directly to the players price one but
thanks to all 2,000 of you with us and
it's Geary's match so far we are where
are we we are fifty five minutes left
currently in the in the time control the
first segment which is five plus one yep
so three games in Geary looking like
he's in charge but we know that to match
and we've seen matches that have looked
like they're going a certain way I mean
karaoke yesterday was up five and a half
three and a half in the five-minute
portion and it ended up losing the match
so I just because Gary's out to an early
lead means doesn't mean nothing but it's
not indicative of the result that will
occur so right now in this game look at
the e5 pawn it's hard to actually take
that pond given the fact that you're F 2
square is very weak so you know you have
to take a little bit of time make sure
that you're safe tuned up your King side
before you even capture that pond and if
I'm black I think how do I want to
protect throw and play f6 and be kind of
passive or go and play move and that's
gonna say e4 that way of politics before
there's Queen Queen trait on d1 fog
Bishop takes e4 and black gets the
better of the ensuing endings so I
really like blacks position here you
can't even play Knight age 4 to win the
bishop pair because Knight age 4 it is a
hanging piece and so everything
seemingly going right for Geary in this
match I mean I just I'm concerned for
mom and Jeff in this early stage don't
be concerned Robert I am concerned look
at his endgame just Bishop g2 King q2 in
park that pony on c4 maybe Knight a5
just well then I gonna make a 5 Maiko
Knight b3 which is a little bit annoying
but I'm just trying to take over the c-4
square I don't want to trade pieces but
I have a better ending like this where I
don't have any material I want to keep
the pieces on the board say you have
these weeks people and double isolated
pawns exactly no it's actually I mean
okay it's a slightly well it's it's a
fundamental lesson right for for
beginners or players just getting
started but really an important one to
understand the importance of keeping
your opponent's weaknesses on the board
don't ever change a structure that's
better for you so I really liked 9005
here coming into c4 okay he's gonna
build up on the pin first the one time
you might actually trade and change your
structures if you were to straight up
winning the pawn so that's gonna put a
shock in a position where he needs to
defend d4 somehow it goes with Bishop e3
but now again so here white has choices
right Knight a5 Knight e5 both of them
are trying to come to c4 that's that
that's the reason why I like Knight a5
better by the way as I was worried about
this even when the bishop was on c1 but
maybe maybe he's okay with this
well the problem was either Knight a5
maybe 3 was particularly annoying
because you're hitting both Knight and
Bishop on c5 and a5 okay of course black
didn't trade on beat on it okay very
nice well you could have maybe traded on
e3 but then Knight takes a5 I see in erm
is oh yeah okay mm-hmm
got it now this is now this is so so
nice nice development then from from
Mahmud Yara bright despite being
positionally worse he's uh he's holding
I I think he's definitely I I have no
idea what just happened there but Oh
Kappa Kappa went crazy on the screen and
the one and only Tommy
donated $69 not exactly sure why he
chose that number but we're gonna say
it's probably because my mom was born in
69 but that's a line my mom was born in
47 so he did it for Arthur for Arthur
that yeah if you're a peaky blinders
Fanueil not talking about
they got him not okay all right well
suddenly shock has turned it around he
needs a win like it's going out of style
right so mama drama of being favored
statistically as far as how we viewed
these guys not something I necessarily
agreed with which I said on Twitter
proof before the match so just FYI but
but yeah it's been an interesting day so
far for Mama gar if he needs to get a
win here maybe he can grind a small edge
now that he's completed his development
yeah already Bishop takes d5 was a
threat so he boom like f6 was made
necessary and okay rook takes d6 trade
on d6 take on c3 we're heading into
especially given that it's one of the
biggest donations we've had so far in
the first round of speeches sham you've
got to read Tommy's message he says
ogirri you're so fine you're so fine you
blow my mind hey Giri so there you go
time what a comedian Tommy Shelby is not
not in the show but in this Tommy
she'll be in the show so polite Nathan
okay well okay finally we get a couple
of results in a row where we're shocked
doesn't and doesn't go down Gary at this
point is two games up in the match so
probably doesn't mind himself a quick
draw especially one that flips the board
around and gives him the white pieces
again so they're right everybody you can
get involved on Twitter if you want if I
could just get the the Twitter to show
on this somehow having some airs with
this OBS thing today so I'm sorry about
that apparently nobody can see there we
go
now we can see it hashtag speed chess
everybody's getting involved and share
with us anything you want they don't
have we don't have any diamond remember
contest right now but if you want to get
involved on Twitter please do yeah and
now I really wanna know as a lot of
commenters do one know what gear is
listening to I'm very curious yeah I
will say that if anybody properly
guesses what gear he's listening to and
his headphones that's worth that's
the diamond membership for sure so there
we go there's our daily contest we
always need one whoever guesses Gary's
music on Twitter I hope someone hopes
own guesses white noise in this correct
I'm open someone guesses Bon Jovi in is
correct or Taylor Swift no come I put it
as like a eighties like American pop
music you thinks I don't know you know
thank you loyal to as you know duska
Patriots like Afrojack or something like
that yeah I don't know probably Peter
dunkers our one and only Peter Dockers
might know what Anisha is listening to
but tweet at us hashtag speech yes if
you get it right one year diamond
membership coming your way that's a
random enough thing that will give a
full year of diamond they are a Geary's
best friend alright here we go
what's next Robert Oh someone said the
fray and I love the fray so good job
Williams yes but what's next what's here
look at this position oh I actually had
a couple lessons with someone who loved
this opening from the black side stand
me from the Budapest and I was like no
don't do this because you just give
white a beautiful Center great bishops
look at your bishop when I fade okay
we'll try to go g6 Bishop g7 so it's not
the end of the world but in do playing
g6 you encourage white to play f4 just
start making more progress in the center
because look at White's position a next
move can be F for it move after that can
be e4 and white Dean's a humongous
center and black is not exactly I agree
these are the type of structures that
are just so much easier to play for
white it's Amarok C bind without the
normal potential compensation right
because it's okay in theory it's
actually a boleslav ski home whenever
the C pawn is here instead of the e pawn
but you have this e 4f for coming a
massive space advantage and black needs
things like b5 d5 sometimes f5 to sort
of undermine those big mirach C centers
and that's just not gonna happen here he
plays a 4 he'll mean Knight g4 either
with just taking it and playing me 4 or
even playing h3 yeah I was gonna say
just take it
get a big center and the bishop here not
a big deal here at this point yeah I
think many players are told that you
know the two bishops sorry that's a
common theme we hear all the time and
they say oh I can't give up on the two
bish
here it's not the biggest deal in the
world I really like that move a for
saying if I Knight takes it for the e4
pawn is now hanging yeah but the point I
was going to make is that the two
bishops are sometimes they're
inconsequential it's that the humongous
center offsets the fact that you have
given your opponent these bishops and
watch out for the move f5 White's move
pawn afford an agenda
Bishop running out of squares exactly an
h3 and g4 come and the Queen on d2 is
very useful here because the Queen can
swing over the Kings side to protect the
new V we can King so here for black you
would love to use the a file and the
reason why work 81 was played is a free
up the a1 square for the bishop because
earlier the a3 we've been very knowing
to deal with we need to put your fish
back to c1 now a three would have loved
that Bishop to return to a 1 and that a
three plants will be staying on standing
on the beautiful diagonal yep yep and
said we have a trouble for this work on
eight you would love to play rook a -
you can't do that with my UNC 3 so you
have this beautiful looking open file
that's not of use for the time being and
if you look at the you know get right
into the center of the board pawn on e4
pawn on f4 you can't go d5 is black
because it just loses upon and you make
move like f6 which says okay if you play
f5 now my bishop goes from h5 over to f7
you just create some weaknesses for
yourself by the same time and white
white has many options right f5 was a
threat based on the fact that the bishop
might have gotten trapped but here I
mean okay you could still just play h3
if you don't like the position of the
bishop and want to use the D file for
the rook you could have played Queen d4
kind of sitting heavy on on a big center
and even Roque one I like it actually
who says the open file belongs to black
right rook a 1 followed by Queen d4
maybe make a trade and ask s Plex Queen
and Bishop what exactly they're doing
over here on g4 and h4 absolutely and
another really bad thing with this
opponent of six Danny is the run
f8 I've mentioned it before what
diagonal is that going to right if uses
tough questions I don't know you know I
have to or somebody somebody's gotta ask
them yeah people are too busy trying to
pacify you out here yeah I'm just trying
to oh I know make you make you think on
your feet
yeah yeah it's it's okay I also want to
take a step back here and say the black
position is not that bad and the reason
why is there are no clear targets to
exploit you know now this Queen an
explorer is surprised by this move f5
now although is he's trying to work out
for now I think we need likes he likes
the Queen as a target rook takes a yay
yeah what I think is such a hugely
committal move it makes the e4 pawn
backward as you highlighted earlier if
that doesn't go well all of a sudden we
got a whole bunch of dark square
problems for whites oh okay b5 b5 is a
temptation for it's not even d5 here I
mean if I can get the bishop on f8 you
asked what diagonal it's getting - well
you gave me purpose
you brought me life on the dark squares
wow that is the most touching thing I
mean in d5 we had 65 yeah we'll have a
moment in a second we can hold each
other off camera but Bishop c5 check I
mean I've got then I go baby back to d6
and hit a ch2 I actually I think the d5
is a real shot yeah I think it's
definitely a possibility
and if you ask me concrete though
because you don't want to just give away
the pawn but you're you know you're kind
of strategically or absolutely correctly
d5 get that Bishop out may put it back
on d6 to attack the King side and that
looks like quite an issue for white so
d5 maybe what we'll throw in g3 first
that looks like a useful move so I can
don't allow your Bishop to come back to
d6 as you were planning to with that
clear tempo so interesting he starts the
rook e8 which i think is reasonable
right saying I'm not gonna commit to d5
to 1/2 than you and you could also bring
the bishop back to h5 now at some point
if you just don't like the rooks
pressure on d6
I mean Bishop a5 the brook moves maybe
then you still look for d5 but it's not
oh okay so rather the bishop off you
like your idea let's justify the bishops
current spot and try to pry open access
to b3
but I think he's doing now desperation
rather than of enjoyment you know it's
like my opponent just hacked my pawn on
d6 I don't really know how to defend it
that well without being passive with
integrity 8yo it so I'm playing from b5
and interesting interesting this is this
naked I mean yeah I really feel like
this is a game that could backfire with
Geary's approach that he opened the dark
squares and something tells me that if
everything just gets simplified beeth be
pawn for D pawn and these two bishops
get out White's King is in danger
and here the e4 is also positioned
anywhere let's say Bishop takes b3 rupee
one Bishop moves somewhere Knight takes
d6 the opposite colored bishops is scary
for white because the bishop on the long
diagonal will it hit the G blue square
whereas blacks structure the
configuration with g7 f6 means that the
bishop the dark strip Bishop will not
have as clear a target so this is not
something I would love to put that pawn
on f5 okay let's take the e4 pawn
footboard and put it back on that three
and that way you blunt the bish or even
all the way back you have to anything
that makes the King feel safer yeah you
know and this is the danger of
overextending a big center if if it
doesn't eventually convert into more
powerful tactics right more space means
your pieces are better but here the
pawns feel overextended now and and the
potential of whites King being weak
means that probably something went went
wrong and I feel like it started to slip
when he overextended with f5 okay
all that said I guess if Geary yeah he
kind of backs up puts his tail between
his legs and hold z4 kind of sits on the
position probably probably not enough to
get after this King
I like that decision because look at
mama here up squat no it don't change
the structure when your opponent is
about to get themselves under time
pressure so and g6 I think objectively
is a pretty good move but when you have
37 seconds it always worries me to walk
into ninety five idea rook b7 potential
sacrifices on f7 is exploiting some of
the weakness this is are the kings with
Bishop d6 right interesting decisions
rook d8 when we met by rook e8 I guess
oh wait a second then yes so rook b8
rook da vote b8 rook takes D 6 cuz Queen
takes T 6 another Queen
anyone checkmate yeah this is uh this is
scary scary yeah if you defend if you
defend the bishop there with the rook
everything gets traded meydani one he
trades still up a pawn but those bishops
will finally get out will they get
enough probably he puts the bishop on d4
no okay he goes back to targeting the e
pawn okay he'll get to d4 it with the
bishop soon no but I agree with you I
mean it wasn't objectively the wrong
decision for black to play this way with
g6 but this gets into a time scramble
again that's a really really risky chess
for mom a jar of twenty seconds but he's
holding he's holding his own here take
with a pawn on g6 yep keep the d5 square
on lockdown okay yep very hard to lose
this endgame is black with the two
bishops but I'm looking at the clock
once more and see 16 seconds left it's
still over here there's probably at some
point Bishop d4 or b4 because now he has
e1 check vision okay he doesn't go for
it king of threes counted regardless
okay Gary's garrison well to push these
like slight advantages yeah you know I
don't blame it'll at all to just keep on
going here there's nothing no risk
whatsoever from White's PW somehow we
managed to hold on to that EEP on
through all the all the smoke you can
bring the knight around if he if he gets
the dark square bishop soph the board
king e5 I guess yeah now he's able to
trade on the eight if you want wait a
second this does not look like a good
transition for mom not at all now he's
one more minor piece trade away from a
winning king upon ending bring the
bishop back put it on d4 yep he does it
play King c4 yep he's on a roll he's on
a roll morning else if I just something
is enough to win here okay h4 now that
was not a good mission before was a
terrible move the pawn can't take as of
this and shucks Wow so frustrated I just
resigns an itch lifting the eyebrows
because okay he'll take it but but he
wasn't happy about that
go but I mean never
he's thrilled about it who am I kidding
but that was that was a big surprise I
need I feel like I need to show that on
the analysis board just to make help
everyone appreciate why the game was
instantly over after Bishop before Wow
just really a huge blunder there I not
one you see from a player of this
caliber really if I'm beating himself up
you know emotionally right now after h4
the point is that captures is not
possible you take an immediate advantage
of the fact that the bishop put itself
on sort of uh on a loose square as they
say right you wanted to keep the bishop
anywhere on the b8 h2 diagonal that
frankly was not f4 or I guess e5 but
moves like this and time pressure they
happen and after h4 the reason Mahmud
you I've resigned is if you can't take
it the bishops gonna move somewhere else
and now h5 comes in and okay I think
like Gary's eyebrows told us it was a
slightly premature resignation right
Robert you would agree with that but I
mean black can play king of seven but it
is it is now a situation where this pawn
is protected and passed which means this
King is free free willy to just come all
the way around the other side of the
board blacks blacks Bishop is
essentially purposeless because with all
these poems on light squares it can't
target anything and and why it's gonna
be pushing forever so still a shocking
early resignation Robert I got to say
but but definitely one of the whites
should win as we said this Bishop has no
purpose and and white can kind of grind
this out in the time scramble yeah I
would not have resigned there I kept
going for sure because it was not that
clear how to make progress in fact I
would not be surprised if black was able
to somehow hold an endgame like that
looks very bad but yeah I mean even if
this King gets like let's try to play
imaginary chests right this white King
gets all the way over to somewhere like
d5 it's they're still not in a super
obvious knockout blow right I think
Mohamed yar I've resigned almost out of
frustration that he played such a bad
move as Bishop before anything else
which is honestly I'm surprised we
haven't seen more of the Tilt emotes
spamming twitch chat because that that's
a bad sign right if you're already
tilting this this early and down three
games in the match
yup and he's shrinking on-screen oh he's
moving up even farther back so it looks
like Samaras getting to him well there
you go best comments ever come from
members like juice so a 4500 be with us
as he doesn't he's never really watched
chess on twitch but speech chess is so
addicting we love that right love that
I've found us however you did as a
twitch user and hopefully you stick
around make sure you follow before you
go anywhere all right Robert the games
go on none of us even with you and I
slightly disagreeing me kinda slightly
leaning Gary's way you leaning Shox way
III don't think any of us predicted a
three game lead at this point in the
match for the Dutchman yeah no I
actually well I changed my tune quite a
bit watching them play earlier like I
said I I you know I know how mommy our
plays over the board but I was not as
impressed with his that's right three
got you changed your pick so I can't
hold that against you
yeah you can hold many things against me
they innate system but little
disposition opposite colored bishops but
look who has the better Bishop and the
answer is black and it doesn't look like
it right now with the pawn chain on f6
me file but it seems like there's a way
for black to actually make progress in
the Queen side look at this pawn on b4
if you play Bishop f8 at the right
moment pawn a five get the c5 square for
your Bishop there's a target on f2 and
when you've obviously colored bishops
the first squares you should look 2 or F
2 and F seven
always you say you look and say well my
bishop has a clear purpose but from the
black side of this position I can play
f5 is black Baxter NZ for you and if I
playing out five I protect my pollen of
six does no longer there
I can pull my Vishwanath they try to get
that Bishop to these diagonal and he
puts Queen d7 first I guess the Queen
wants to spy on the a Foursquare people
I've worked 81 I may just go over there
and play for and shut okay but Jacques
knows knows his principle chess too and
he plays c5 even if he loses that pawn
don't be surprised if he's doing
everything he can to just help his
Bishop his light square Bishop get going
whether it's e to D 1 B 3 well however
however he finds his way to the a to g8
diagonal as Robert said whenever you're
playing Ops code Bishop positions
yeah the activity of your bishop just
takes on even more importance for for
everything
Gary's gonna trade though and probably
the c5 pawn won't be on the board too
much longer the question is will shock
get light score compensation in the
meantime well I would have taken applied
rook b1 like almost immediately
okay if everyone knew it you would have
taken and played rook b1 even though you
just lose the C pawn these rugby sevens
coming and the very least I have quite a
good deal of compensation there I I mean
I could play if I here yeah I mean I
think d4 coming actually but the e pawn
being pinned is kind of a precise okay
that's kind of a same point I see all
right well the ladies depart either way
here comes Bishop f8 I'm guessing since
that's the the move you called for
before seems to make a lot of sense yeah
Bishop if Anna guests waiking and
siblings c6 and there were p7 next but
yeah I don't know it looks like mama di
was on too rough with shape in this game
and looked at he's leaning back he's
literally doing the rocket way you know
what sometimes you got a lean back he's
gonna need to brush his shoulder off in
the middle of this break though because
at some point here this has to turn
around or it's gonna be a runaway so Wow
Bishop f8 rook the rook ba this is just
a position that Geary probably again
can't lose which given the mass
situation is a pretty good result yeah
and let's see for white you don't d4 is
one of those moves where you want to
gain space no pump your bishop but then
perhaps you're putting your pawn another
week square on the d4 square way on d3
is very well defended right the threat
is the rook takes b1 rook takes Bishop
takes c5 or Bishop takes c5 right away
because ether is hanging with check so
you need something as white you don't
want to take on b8 and you'll you liked
having you I was gonna say you had you
really have to play d4 given how you're
describing it because the only option
would have been let move like c6 but
then a3 hangs this is exactly what I was
worried about right there's a chain of
dark square pawns which are now
vulnerable to attack and Gary's really
doing everything right
thus far he's just poking and prodding
in every moment yep and you know I've
been while looking at this game in
Boston reflecting the last game his
poking and prodding has resulted in you
know mom you're collapsing in that last
game I think mommy you're signed in a
drum Wow
just tells you this tells you how
frustrated shock is right now taking a
sip of tea let's hope that there's a
little something extra in that to help
him get the juices flowing because I
mean yes that was frustrating to be in a
position where you did got outplayed
again in a middle game and an obstacle
bishop advantage became a huge one but
this is uh this is this is a shocking
start to this match not to say that you
know when players of this level get
going the Robert we talk about that
we're you know classes permanent formas
temporary right sometimes one of them
doing really well we saw that happen
with Aronian versus Fabiano right where
it was I mean I don't think that you
play that match back seven times ten
times that it's that big of a lopsided
victory for LaVon but it was like LaVon
had everything going Fabiano couldn't
find it as soon as that tilt hits and a
player of 2,800 strength doesn't take
their foot off the gas I guess that can
happen right I mean it almost feels like
that's where we're headed today unless
mama JA returns it around quickly
absolutely you know it's tough to be
down four games to anyone let alone one
of the top players in the world than
these Curie was what number six in the
world these girls and you know very
difficult spot and this game reminds me
of the game where Gelfand beat Anand by
the yeah this is in Raisa the game where
Galvin beat Anand where he just went
down the C file got a slightly better
position and and defeating him like that
so I'm not just well it came from a
different opening that's for sure but
similar he reminds what you're really
talking about the blind of white has on
the queenside to kind of go with the C
file right you've got this night well
placed on a for the night on d7 doesn't
really want to leave and go challenge it
because the white knight on f3 can come
to e5 the bishop on b7 is really just so
not a good piece sorry that that sounded
a really simple way to describe it but
it's not a good piece right so kind of
the bind on the Queen side going with
the C
file is even though I yeah it wasn't the
same opening as the as the golfing game
but no it's not but I mean just the two
on one on the queenside the blacks
pieces are very limited that's a good
thing in a white structure local fish
money seven there's no gag go to d6 but
but there so be it yeah exactly and now
night c5 played to hit this 997 try to
attack this on b7 as well if you
take on c5 well now I just take with my
pawn and it's just especially important
that my rooks and c1 because we got it
see Saints didn't pass there you just
add water in step a sir Bishop would go
back to see if he can even bring the
bishop back to d3 if he wants here you
might just stare at it because the Queen
protects it so Oh another tactic and
look at Geary smiling as he Bob's his
head you know why it's almost like he
knew we didn't see it so that was a that
was a giftable moment right there Gary
taking that with a big smile Wow
yeah look at this because pawn on e6
Queen e6 check if your rook f7 of course
is 90 g5 coming and if like King h8 the
ship takes d7 and then I take 97 and
I've simply gone up what two pawns
I found that smirk to be so funny right
Gary's got the the handsome charm going
got the smile going the head Bob that's
Wow can you say five game lead Robert I
may not be able to put those words in my
mouth but sweat spots of being right and
crazy
they say ball don't lie in basketball
but here score is not lying in chess and
Gary else across 3,000 in his rating so
woof wow that was a shot and you know
it's funny because from a principle
point of view I guess we shouldn't be
you know super super shocked by just
went down because if you look at if you
look at the direction blacks pieces
we're going everyone this is pieces
going backwards right you're undeveloped
ting them onto the back rank those are
the situations where tactics happen and
so good fundamental lesson for everybody
we highlighted that this seemed like a
similar game where you and I saw Gelfand
crush and on but
really good lesson to see that Queen
before it's the only move here Danny
well I guess you go to g3 no Jeju
doesn't work Queen before is the only
move yeah
oh sorry to you know I was trying to do
the instructional thing but you're
you're what you're saying is more
important black has somehow swindled
white but okay Queen before still works
just fine yeah the point is if you move
your queen anywhere Oh Queen c5 also
works I guess but the plane was black
has threatened Oh Queen before Knight g4
wait a second oh the attack is flipping
how you how you getting out of this Gary
Gary leaning in and shock doing the the
Leanback Rockaway wouldn't that be
wouldn't that be funny if Gary's if
Gary's tactic and smile
you know rebalance cuz of a cause of a
blunder cuz cuz Queen g3 here Queen take
c1 check Bishop c1 Brooke take c7 white
is in no danger whatever night takes us
6 9 f 6 a maybe Brooke e 7 I have rook
c8 no but I'll go Queen c1 right and
then when I take you take e7 at least at
least I'm not just losing there right
right same idea with what move as are
you saying with g3 right you take on c1
I take back to the breakup and same idea
but I mean it reminds me of the moment
where Carlsen hushed the crowd at the
sink filter out for in the live
commentary and they you know it kind of
didn't work out in his favor yeah the
the well first of all I love the swag
anyway I loved his hush moment I'm sure
those who are subscribed to the st.
Louis which ball will start spanning
down here in a second but but yeah I
know it's interesting interesting when
you see the top players doing things
that they witness other players do like
in basketball right Steph Curry makes a
three and shushes the crowd but but here
it might you know the the smirk might be
coming back to haunt Anish because that
was Wow okay well he'd better have a
defense 294 yeah he's boxed the e-file
and just laughs in the face of danger
Simba what in the world
so Queen f2 th1 you can't you know you
just you can go to h4 because if I take
you have rookie
working when made right yes I was trying
to figure out but you've h3 there and
the night f2 check you've King Wow to
the to the Batcave we go what's going on
yeah when he takes up to King h1 Queen
h4 if Knight takes everyone we have mate
h3 and somehow white is defending and
then yeah and I don't not have to check
if King f2 is mentioned in Queen takes
ages you as scary as it looks actually
has nothing so in fact Gary knows it
Dearing knows this no now he's gonna be
sure she is
if Gary knew we were talking about he
should give us the yeah we just got a
little bit too excited about shocks
attack there yeah but so Queen f2 KH 195
if you take back any fight with the pawn
queen takes b2 is a hanging Bishop so
okay now I have six worst-case scenario
right um I gotta still be better in the
singing with the e pond yeah you must
absolutely but if no you're right of
Queen if to king over 95 I guess that
that probably is the best this is this
of course is scary for white right I
mean yeah I just started gobbling up
pieces my Queen has the e4 square Queen
f2 of course is the threat if you go
rook F one
perhaps I even have to move Knight h2 as
a huge nuisance for you you have Queenie
for check as well right Queenie for TD -
I matter King myself oh I guess I have
some reason I thought I had night h2 to
f3 I forgot your meadow an f-35 just
guards a3 I'd really love to play
Queenie for Chuck and then get my knife
from g4 to e4 go to fork emote but but
no it feels like Black is running out of
power moves here to keep the attack
going nice she's a good move move the
rook
somewhere safe perhaps - that's 2 e1 and
then you can play King D 1 Kings c1 just
kind of but can I just go Knight g4 back
but then I just came from g4 and let's a
go with rook e1
Knight g4 run forest run king d1 tonight
have to shanxi one oh I can't go rook
takes no why because I get amazing work
and can't take on e5 oh look it's you
give me run Forrest run reference that
actually paid off the rare moment I mean
okay he goes to d1 but I think I think
the King just needs to get out of judge
yeah and Queen f3 check there's just
King D 2 and after wait Queen f3 check
there's King you okay so they're
repeating a little bit so this is what
the rook on d1 Oh that with rook e1 ran
into Queen f3 check teen d2 Queen takes
f2 check and it's looking she's looking
sketchy I don't know it might not be so
terrible but doesn't look great honestly
so he's he's trying to bail out with the
draw and mama drove you know is thinking
about Queen f3 check here and saying
maybe I can make a little bit of
progress
yeah I'm not Robbie he just needs to
repeat though I mean this is don't you
already sort of have been given a gift
here given that you had such a horrible
opening and blundered Knight takes c6
yeah I think he's making the right
decision to just repeat it
I don't know that Gary's making the
right decision I like the idea of rook
e1 that we talked about and running the
King but he didn't do it so well rook e1
the again the beats your Bishop was
always hanging so it's a queen up to
check there's those Queen takes b2 so
you couldn't run too far without losing
that there's no no in a line I gave with
Knight h2 rookie one night back to c4
King d1 right maybe you know Queen f2
it's very complicated
it is certainly risky and I guess from
Gary's perspective a draw is still okay
22 minutes left here in the five minute
thanks to all roughly 4000 of you with
us appreciate your support I appreciate
all of our subscribers premium members
watching both chats just calm TV twitch
chess Robert does nothing but watch the
chat we've got like seven monitors on
his wall I'm really curious this is
gonna be a turning point imagine Geary
stubbornness remain dominant dhaumya
given that he he really should have won
that one and pushed it and okay he
almost bled her mate and and barely held
a draw so yep you know I wonder if it's
like poking the bear it's all good and
fun and everything's
right the bear Putin knows about
that oh boy not getting into this kind
of conversation you should just pass the
test
good job appreciate that why are people
saying thanks Robert what I do I don't
know people keeps I've got a bunch I'm
looking at the twitch app you were
saying hi hi Robin thanks Robert
I don't know that I don't know either
okay anyway they'll get whites position
here it's why also the name of the
opening is the Clemens opening each
three was played on the first move do we
did we skip over that fact I did three
was played this is uh this is shock just
trying to age 3d5 night of three okay it
immediately transposed into something
you know it was so traditional from the
perspective it's a ready structure that
we just didn't notice I guess yeah and I
well I would say what is the Clemens
opening I know I don't know the Rings
openings that well but I've never heard
the Clements oh I've heard of you know
Roger Clemens but yes
Burgie still thinking you Robert I don't
know what's going on there they love you
Robert
thank you Robert what's the deal I think
it's cuz you're keeping me in check
somehow I think this is joking now and
wait what this looks terrible from what
yeah this is uh you you called it would
this be a turning point in the match
something that poked the bear and okay
Geary desperately parts with the dark
square bishop and here here why can just
take back in the ephah okay I thought II
five was coming and maybe there was
tactics on f7 but watch out for your
Bishop was hanging on c4 those okay yeah
but this is just I mean look at that
bish one d5 you play Bishop e6 I mean
okay you can just leave it there I
wanted to play c4 but I can't get away
with it I see for you x-ray oh yeah I
started rook b1 or something like that
just if you take on d5 like Bishop e6
rupee one Bishop takes d5 like Queens
five and a lot Queens pretty well placed
well yeah this is somehow looks more
manageable for black now than it did
yeah check now actives looked a lot
scarier than what's happening but okay
but even just simple moves for a white
queen d3 bring the other rook over to d1
I mean yep or even I guess Queen d2 does
that threaten Queen h6 and 95 I love it
absolutely I really like Queen d2 all of
a sudden 22 is the ferocious also play a
5 that's the positional I'm the Queen d2
just and that's speaking to me now you
talking to double on the D file you're
trying to Queen h6 as you point out that
mama bird will feed you I'll feed you
baby birds Queen d2 oh he doesn't go for
it goes the wrong way he's just saying
doing that you can go your own way no
hey I got it don't worry no from you
know a little more he would Mac in my
life but all right it's all good okay so
he puts his rook on d1 Bishop takes d5
Queen 65 the 96 is no we're good to go
that's a huge problem is a 5 is a threat
to expose the fact the brook and queen
on the same line Queen c7 is certainly
an option here but is why can't place c4
and just say I'm I'm gonna solidify my
center we're gonna put a 5 first the
knight on d6 just not at all this is not
a blockade where the knight is happy in
front of a pawn this is a dangerous open
file Queen e7 you can trade on e6 is
there some tactics like taking on e6 and
if we trade everything can I place
things like Knight g5 and your rook is
overwhelmed guarding the night yes yes
you can zhilie Bishop e6
Queen e6 Queen seems working 6 9 g5 you
play rookie 5 have them f4 was attacking
rook and protecting my knight if you
work f6 in your movie 5 certainly comes
into play so after Bishop e6 you take
with the pawn on e6 and that looks ugly
but how bad it is another question it
doesn't look very good yeah I mean it's
a it's a nightmare to have to open the
king in this way but it might be
theories on the option given the
situation so surprise shock is taking
someone on Bishop takes East six Wow
goes a different direction just wants to
keep that Bishop there theory still
bobbing his head still relaxed
apparently despite being worse for is
this the first time in the match where
we can really say that the shock was
just better out of the opening and in
better middlegame feels like it right it
feels like mama door just has not had an
edge until what are we at now game seven
game eight yep and now he should do
place C takes B five eight six from
Bishop takes six like that now is now
it's the perfect form a key six and
force F takes I don't know if he
realizes that f66 is like a necessity
but I think I mean there's no way you
can't he's not calculating this whole
idea that night chief okay he sees it I
mean somehow appreciated that Giri was
not gonna take on d5 anyway right so he
didn't take on e6 right away but there's
no way Giri wanted to capture there and
give him such a very powerful pass pawn
so easy five now you attack tonight you
win the b5 pawn and this is horrendous
for blacks because even if you win this
b5 pawn back my night is gonna some at
some point reached the e4 square and
once it reaches me for you know exactly
I'll smell highlighting it before you
can say it right on the F spot the yeah
now this looks like a game that will be
a real turning point in and perhaps
something we can ask Erie about after
the match if and in how and maybe how
Jacques felt if it does indeed prove to
something that gives them a springboard
to a much closer match than we've seen
so far
'if I've this looks very bad for Geary
look here he's like leaning in I mean
just see him staring intently at the
board but it's a really tough position
because pawn takes a for pawn takes d6
pawn takes B well actually yeah if I say
you may go for it his pawn takes d6 pawn
takes b3 pawn takes I was gonna say
that's interesting he just recognizes
his opportunity to take a super
practical approach rather than getting
grinded all night with the the bad
weaknesses on the on the squares you
discussed with the knight here he's he's
gonna try to put the pressure instead no
lionel richie for an itch no no all
night long man you sometimes catch me
off guard
no but it's true though he didn't want
it you didn't want to be put in that
spot you know to be to be ground down
what any water honestly it's a sign of a
very good player when you recognize the
momentum you know the the practical
opportunity to change the nature of the
game just from a psychological
perspective can sometimes get to get a
media blunders from your opponent
because they were calculating
comfortable ways to grind down a slight
edge and now now even though white
probably should be winning okay right
it's gonna be a different type of game
yeah white is definitely winning here
objectively but you know we saw actually
we saw this the last round of the
Sinquefield Cup Levon Aronian with white
against I was in Accra shook all of a
sudden Levon sacrifices a rook and end
up being an exchange but he was
objectively according to the engines
worse but he would have been worse no
matter what so he changed the dynamic of
the game and that led to his victory now
he's shaken in not not thrilled with his
rookie for a move he wants to go rook c4
to go rook see to in the night c4 and
when he pond oh yeah but the problem is
that the rook c4 rook takes c4 Knight
takes four before you couldn't get away
with taking on B - because after Knight
takes b2 you're pinned and then
Blackwood went c4 c3 and one that night
so you know it's still good here because
he's blockading these pawns or is he I
mean I think it's pretty straightforward
yeah I mean the King comes up you could
even check the knight on e4 yeah he's
just in time cuz you know black was
showing over up e3 pawn c3 pawn c2 but
with the King already on d2 it's clearly
over in a bad I think Anish will resign
for the first time in the match today
and we've seen a couple results go
Mahmoud yards way right speaking of you
can go your own way
Robert waiting for another lonely day
we'll talk about his dating life later
and there you go
man you make cross-references like turn
up and tap I don't know I'm a
cross-reference
is like Steph Curry crosses over okay
there we go
mom a jar of winds and the you start to
see some Mahmud yaar of emails coming
out for the first time today
UNC the awesome clearly voting for
shocked and there you go
Anisha is ozone din we only have 12
minutes left here in the five-minute
portion which means in theory this could
be the last game of course we will let
the let the players know if that becomes
the case and so three game lead this is
a would be a big time for for mom and
job to cut it to two and you know again
add the bullet thing worries me for mama
Jarvis seeing him play that before we
just saw e4 we just saw h3 and the last
game Pomodoro was white now he's played
d4 and I see six so apparently shock
decided that the main line weapons
weren't working out for him against Gary
Gary came prepared to challenge him
theoretically and Jacques gonna do
whatever he can to mix it up from here
on out it looks like cuz d4 Knight c6 is
uh well it's not something you see very
often when 228 hundreds are playing for
a good reason
developing tonight blocking the c-pawn
positionally black is usually much worse
in this type of structure and okay here
black is still a little bit worse but
not nearly as bad as you would have
thought so
h3 worked for him maybe one night c6
will work for him Bobby yeah you know
he's gone with offbeat openings all the
time and it's no I I can't decide yet if
that's a good decision based on the
results it's not and I know you call me
Bobby but I chose certain okay well you
don't make choices okay and here it
actually doesn't look so bad because
he's offering a series of exchanges his
position is such that he's a
three-on-two majority on the queenside
whereas in the center Gary has the four
on three and what's so nice of having
that four on three is if you're able to
play moves like efore f45 that's what
you really want to get set up here
you're just not in time because the bish
25 could always take on C 3 e 4 is very
hard to get in here ok bishop
things g3 rook takes out five comes
that's a plan yeah that would be a nice
shot if your Giri we know that I was
gonna said Queen h4 it no I think I'd be
as well cuz you get up seven but check
and and then can deal with the meet
later
no I'll same bishop aids to check Queen
h4 check or the Bishop you exactly
so now Queen f6 was the necessary move
and what c6 here is is one option okay
it takes first and this looks like the
worst is behind black just looks Bishop
e6 trade off the bishops yeah I mean the
the long-term edge favors black in these
types of end games as you highlighted
earlier
three-on-two parlament you already much
more effective at creating a passed pawn
but white owns the only open file that's
the D file and so there's it's always a
matter of activity I mean here you can
just move the rook back to d4 or even d2
yeah I think d2 is fine
and as long as Geary owns the D file
that means he's the only one with
threats of penetrating to the seventh
rank the only one with threats to to
swing from one side of the border
together so the open file I think keeps
white with a slight edge here despite
blacks three-on-two yep so before okay I
was gonna say black needs to place c5 b5
and a quick sequence to gain more space
but now before for stop c5 my boss it it
encourages a5 but after 85 is played why
would then go b5 and say my opponent d5
makes it so that your pawns about moving
on the BNC files
yeah slightly better for white whether
it's enough for win is a totally
different story
I'm I don't think so well now work d8
yeah you can rip d8 and then now you
just tasting flavor I was gonna say you
can deliver a 5 and Queen of three at
some point to hit b7 he goes clean up
through right away
so if Queenie forms like a draw and
Queen s new Queen f6
you got to be careful though you don't
let the Queen start getting in there
although actually Queenie for Queen f6
we know six in the rook da sculling but
I was wondering if I get away with
Queens eggs be flow you were
would dirty-girl Queen - that's Gary
that's not necessary
right there no you defend no but my name
is rook 1 to d7 at the end of that very
second it's just like you're you're
giving up the seventh rank
let me black him to defend with Queen c4
Queen b3 but yeah I hear you it's scary
yeah maybe it may be defensible just
looking for that was a good time to use
a minute on the clock or 45 seconds no
this looks pretty level I think yeah
well I could just say forget the Queen's
and play rook d7 right now right I know
then I guess you just take B for anyway
because you're still protecting the rook
although then you favor key 7 Queenie
sound Queen d7 and you yeah d7 feels
natural and you know let's say you trade
on f3 okay the Queen's are off but I do
on the seventh rank and some small edge
to keep playing for yep
okay wait yeah rook d7 he would trade to
play king of fate so I think at the end
of the day of his trade Queens and bring
that came towards the center and said
it's not so bad but Queen affords a nice
job of this you're trying to change the
pawn structure in a favorable way now
he'll go tricky seven likely I'm just
being followed our name here rook d7
there if you play Queen takes before now
you can take on no you as your queen um
beef okay I was again testing you and
you're passing all my little tests I'm
throwing at you it's just a public
service I provide to make sure that my
blunders are caught by your tactics well
I knew my best so yeah now the king will
get to e8
white will be forced to relinquish the
seventh rank and this should be peaceful
like we thought it would be for a while
honestly blacken is the one who can
start trying to play for more because
this is where the three-on-two majority
really comes into play not only is it
allows you to create a passed pawn but
it means that White's pieces are
starting to have
shift towards the Queen side and white
on the other hand has this four-on-three
majority but doubled pawns yeah but
there's also entry ways for the king
right you've got this outside kimchi
three king aged for kimchi five and then
you can push f5 through so there's some
there's some flexibility
what you got I mean you just have a
really hard time doing that when I have
a passed pawn I guess that's sort of
yeah yeah that is the ideal setup for
white was playing trying to play for f5
and get rid of one your double pawns to
create a passed pawn of your own but for
the time being black has everything
covered it's me rook d5 will come to
play for for white so that you can't
play okay so next outrage over rook d5
I'm guessing yeah rook d5 and rook II
does he said or watch Ricky Bahl take
take him over b7 and yeah that would be
a good lesson in never never allow your
opponent to get a rook so easily behind
a passed pawn get your rook behind the
passed pawn so dipper rescue Brooke
ending lessons all the time they're
always present well how does black
actually protect this pawn again yeah
not only is white threatening repeat 1
but I'm also now I can focus on the
things I wanted to do on the Kings side
if possible Brooke b1 the right just
your move yeah I mean rope you wanna
make sense uh oh yeah it's good the pawn
falls and then Y can slowly work on what
we talked about
f 3 e for a king h4 try to get f5 and
break up the structure so you know
gearing once again kind of coming out on
top of the critical middle game position
and f5 immediately yeah this is this is
not okay this is one of those ones that
theoretically should probably be a draw
but this is really not an easy draw
definitely especially in time pressure
seems very strong for a masters losses
over the board let alone and bliss I'm
trouble yep so this is not gonna be easy
yeah
g3 you just work it forward efore comes
and then king of 4-3 eventually you're
in a position where the kingdom pawns
have advanced you'll bring the rook to
the sixth rank to create threats of e5
and if that happens then the King has to
retreat in the moment the black King has
to go back because of threats on the
pawn then White's King can enter and
then we get problems so here we go
that's what we just talked about this is
the the best way to hold is to try to
prevent white actively rather than
prevent it by backing up your King but
gonna be a lot of poking and prodding
before white just lets black have a draw
here yeah white my adventure played g4
that's you know some moment just to keep
the game going in the West I was gonna
say rook d3 King III rook t4 that get
the black rook off the fourth-ranked
first because if you can if you can
trade the e pawn for the F pawn first
and then you open up checks for the
white rook before you've kind of let him
let him get rid of his weakness on h5 so
I I like this for blacks gonna play
Brooke a5 after King a4 here just to try
to oh no he lousy five well no you mean
you're you kind of highlighted the exact
setup necessary to hold these positions
yeah
black needs the setup to pretty much
stay exactly as it is in Mahmud jarvez
has done just that this is you know it's
instructive because I think very often
these types of n games are lost in your
own games talking to the fans and I mean
in my games as well because you try to
change too much there are a lot of rook
endings where you do have to have an
active defense that prevents a plan but
there's just as many rec endings like
this right Robert that basically the way
you would lose this is by doing too much
if you find a way to sit tight and make
it really clear that your opponent has
no plan this is this is often your best
defense right yep and okay I like what
Gary finally did is he pushed upon which
means he can play for another 50 moves
and he'll try to do so King up to now
eventually what's gonna happen the brook
will come to the six ring threatening me
five and if black checks the King
forever he'll walk in
from g2 to h3 and h4 he's gonna put his
rookie 76 I think he's gonna play f5 for
sticking to h6 oh wait a sec you're
right at 5:5 convenient little problem
for black rook f7 he's not any time
searching age 6 or 7 Brooke b6 lin
rui-qing d14 III King before yeah I
think this was a a really bad idea of
note that King g5 would actually get
yourself really in a tough spot allowing
white to retransmission the rook to g6
so this is not no I don't think so at
all I think like is actually objectively
lost now even yeah well rookie 7 you
have rook a1 saving the Mary looking
good rook f8 first exactly rook f8 team
g7 member PA and the point everyone the
reason we want the rook to the e-files
cuz then you're threatening rookie 6 so
eventually the route gets here you play
rook e6 and either the rook has to
retreat and lose the pawn or you have to
trade and lose the King upon ending so
the rookie 7 immediately as Robert said
will be met by the back door mate threat
but there will be some way likely for
black to get this rookie 7 rookie 6 idea
sorry for white and this is gonna be the
last game of the 5 minute portion unless
they finish the next three you know 4
seconds ohyeah 95 yet yes good move King
III how do you can a 5 in
this is officially the last game we'll
make sure that that our team has has
informed them of this fact they have
been notified that it is the last game
we will be prepared to abort the next
game just in case they didn't get our
messages the heat of the moment
sometimes lets our emotions get the best
of us but if this ends in in the lead
being pushed back to four games as we
think it might although again shock kind
of holding in a weird way I want white
to try to play with the key one I've
brought the King to age three a long
time ago because then you can play e5
okay he's going for a different approach
here but it's not 40 triangle key h5
nokia strive and then go e5 no why is he
avoiding if the King was on a street
while the palmist on the board a five
could have been played which is what I
wanted this whole time
well then rookie five was happening so
you always like has this annoying rook
attack from the fifth rank really I
don't buy that that wasn't the winning
plan
this is actually that does a kind of
winning I'm looking at it on the
analysis board and if I back up and
eventually I have no idea what you're
doing once my rook most my King got to
h3 yeah no it's very it's very tough I
mean the threat would have been a five
and there's literally no way to stop at
the rook can no longer move with a check
rise gonna wait for you to play e5
before went rook a five but that still
looks pretty pretty challenging from
black because you take on f6 and bring
your king up to age four so okay well
Gary looks like he's about to give a
draw which would be a moral success if
there is such a thing in chess for Mama
Garvin
but maybe maybe he'll find a way to win
anyway that's what he's gonna try to do
despite maybe they and mom Jarvis no
time no look at this mind your blender
and lost inside Wow
a frustrating frustrating result
therefore Mahmoud Gaurav and the truth
is a pretty frustrating five-minute
segment if we're honest we go over to
the scoreboard and not that you didn't
know it already from those little
numbers next to their avatars there on
chess calm but it's a six and a half two
and a half lead for the Dutchman Robert
what does mahmoud yar of need to do we
know his manager was tom great guy thank
you for all your help is with him maybe
giving advice what's your advice for
mama sheriff to try to make a comeback
here in the next portion
maybe tell him to start playing more
typical openings I mean the openings
haven't always been at fault for his
defeats but I think he can play
something a little bit more mainstream
and mainline that way he can just play
quickly and more confidently because
he's getting in positions that he's not
familiar with and at the beginning the
very first game is there was a good idea
now I'm backtracking because he was like
Geary is the one who came Bretton to
play and neutral territory is where Gary
wants it
whereas mama-jama needs things to be up
Israel house alright well we'll see what
mama D Aarav has in store for us in the
three minute portion either way we just
spent the last 30 minutes kritis you
know it's going way but you're well you
know what's going your way
tongue-tied when no we spent the last 30
seconds criticizing gear
for not having the winning plan but he
gets a win on time anyway we'll be right
back in about 90 seconds everyone is the
players take a quick break s and I will
do the same don't go anywhere the
three-minute portion is coming right up
well we'll see if if shocked heard your
advice to transition himself to slightly
more main lines maybe time to bust out
that opening Theory that's gotten him
over 2,800 and currently rated number
three in the world that being Chuck
rearmament Gaurav so either way he's got
to do something here Robert he's down
four games the players are getting set
to come back not quite here but in just
a moment we will start the games as soon
as we see mahmud yard of show his face
there we go we got a subscription right
as we have a moment to say hi to the
fans shout out to the Desroches $93
already donated we haven't hit the three
minute or one minute portion the the
players thank you we've also got to
remind everybody that anything you
purchased today in the merch store we
just added some speeches championship
commemorative mugs we know you're into
that kind of thing anything you purchase
in the in the store goes directly to the
prize fund today for the players so get
yourself some swag while you're while
you're here
all right the games have begun
three-minute chess is underway and as
Erie apparently Roberts advice not taken
because the the mix-up continues here
and it is part of the reason why Gary's
been able to play faster more
comfortably right Robert I mean he's
he's getting positions that aren't very
challenging to be honest yeah it's been
pretty perplexing to see mom a jar of
game after game but he's just trying to
have fun
and honestly in the st. Louis rapid and
blitz he was doing things like this as
well he put this early g4 against rh4 I
should say against a cardiac inand a
really fascinating game so he's he's
shown a been city to have abnormal
openings and just play chess on his own
terms so look at this position c4 saying
that your Bishop e2 is gonna be locked
in and your bishop on b2 is gonna be
locked in simultaneously because your
own pawn and all right he's gonna for
now
I assume that's look for the only way to
overcompensate for all your weaknesses
as you've highlighted these bad pieces
is to over control other squares hashtag
nimzowitsch eat your heart out right
I knew this as soon as there we go it's
time it's time let's go as they say and
where's my g4 emote where's it at
give it to me baby is there a g4 you my
subscribers to my channel oh it's your
channel gosh yeah I know how to bring it
on the g-spot
I got chief four over there on my
channel bring it Oh game on the
commentary continues and we are excited
to be here Robert tell us how a Z recess
is gonna justify this ridiculous move
where the best move on the board right
now is to move the pawn backward Agito
yeah it's hard to justify it but I do
think he made an interesting decision
because it did make a niche thing that's
at least some sort of progress
kingi - he's gonna slowly work his way
to plant it play f3 first I guess just
to kick this night out maybe he'll play
I have four right away but I yeah
kicking the night makes sense and if you
play f4 blacks and just go for f6 and
that's kind of annoying it ends my
nights strong okay so d5 is hanging now
but f6 kicks them and away from me v
quickly enough so that after have 696 BC
six the pond e5 is well defended and not
really feeling White's positional the
Pawnee target I mean we make jokes about
it but the truth is this is this is just
the kind of structure you would really
frown upon all your students doing you
know justifying opening up and opening
up their own King without one weaknesses
to really attack in black structure and
and to not the type of center or
position where we're white is gonna be
able to keep it closed f6 is gonna pry
things open and usually that's the best
way to take advantage of someone who
willingly exposed their own King open up
the center and you know he's gonna be
regretting this this chief or move I
think you should play e4 here oh and
then Bishop takes c3 yeah just loses the
pawn straight up right and here comes f5
yeah I mean it may be a clinic here if
Geary gets a win like this and
and shock doesn't turn things around a
little bit less desperate chefs this is
a bad sign it's a it's a tilt sign yeah
this has been almost unpleasant to watch
in a weird way because I've been so
impressive my jar of and recent let's H
five here for black cannot be a bad
movie five first so now would you go a
may f4 I don't want to play that move
because then Queen g6 and I hate my
position so don't hate yourself no I
said I hated the position on myself how
icky for I think II for might be the
move now there it is okay this actually
is not so his hair that was key move
because especially if the Queen's come
off the board it's the one way it would
feel better everything that he did to
was on his own king not gonna get made
it anymore
but after takes and then takes c3 I'll
probably go back to winning that e4 pawn
but then I've had Bishop before isn't in
between move and say okay upon C for be
hanging my Bishop is gonna get new life
in the position you're a guy takes your
first Knight takes now the point is if
you take we Bishop takes c4 with check
first
Intermezzo yep this actually I agree it
turned around there it okay if black
takes you take on c4 with check I even
play Bishop e6 though you trade
eventually I'll just show it on the
analysis board I don't know why I have
to highlight so much yeah I'm thinking
Bishop phase g4 here for black I don't I
think black is still better in this end
game that's my point even if we even
with the the survival simplification by
by shock to get the Queen's off the
board again I think it's the right thing
his King was open but the black is still
better in the second just take it
oh yeah I have to take Bishop takes c4
there's no mate this should be sex yeah
see it's a Bishop f3 here is that
possible
and about three feet of rookie six
doesn't go d5 but maybe I it's not
enough and because I've a d5 you go
Brooke g6 was very important move to hit
my g4 pawn so yeah this is not looking
particularly lovely they should be six
even so taken well I like this move
order for white because at least now
your rooks on e4 and the same thing that
Crichton
instead of hitting cheap or you've got a
little bit of time play c4 tried to get
d5 both for a passer and to open up your
Bishop on b2 no I I think he's he's seen
the worst of it but if I'm if I'm giri i
have rook b8 i have Brooke 88 okay he
plays that one now we're threatening
brookie to in a lot of positions so
Brooke g6 is a temptation for sure
that's a good move because now King
enters my III check Oh Richard
SpaghettiOs
King H Newseum c7 is mate and then rook
h3 he missed it oh my god Gary just
missed a mate Bishop c7 it doesn't
matter you know it's going well for you
again we keep saying it when Gary misses
a force maid but still takes it home mom
a jar of just refusing to wade into the
the home preparation waters where we
know these 2800 s have a lot of stuff
cooked up real nice and and he doesn't
want to play prep and again a we
highlighted that the beginning of the
match and not to go back to something we
predicted that Gary Gary wants this more
than Mahmud yarv right now in it and
it's showing and it's impressive
honestly it's you know we've been
criticizing mom and Jairus play quite a
bit but we should certainly be praising
Geary at play yeah just it's very
one-sided I almost thought you rolled
your eyes at me right there that I
realize on you know why would I roll my
eyes at you exactly I don't know don't
get sad Danny don't get your so
clean-shaven today it hurts you how old
are you 18 16 well 17 and you haven't
seen again
all right well Gary again not gonna shy
away from getting a big edge out of the
opening if Mahmoud yarv wants to play
chess this way Gary's gonna go for I
mean white is already crushing through
with e5 this is the kind of pure that
gets people to quit the opening I mean
we talk a lot about the French and and
you said it's a good bliss opening but
how is white not just threatening
castles long 94 and Bob's your uncle
I mean this is just a crushing position
for white looks not good
85 is out of desperation by the way
because h3 was a threat for those for
those who care the night that night was
almost trapped there and not even move
10 don't Castle queenside yet because f2
is hanging but you know you could play
h3 first and there it goes 96 abyssal
Queen side by the way there's threats
like Knight takes b5 and then Bishop
takes b5 check if you really want to be
aggressive because the Queen is
overwhelmed to the d8 square that looks
very tempting Bishop takes me far from
when they defy us and even better look
at you outdoing me that's why your mom
loves you more that's the only one of
the ranch she loves you more than me ya
know this looks I mean what do you have
to do here is black because Bishop e5 on
95 is coming now you you prevent this
sacrifice but again the the more
straightforward approaches 94 95 g4 g4 i
won't i won't reference exactly what i
did before but you know I'm gonna bring
the emote I mean how many times am I
gonna get to use this today can we get a
prop that going yeah this is this is so
so if you take on g4 on g4 Bishop takes
g4 lights you know Bishop g2 and B will
there's already an overwhelming amount
of pressure in the on the D file and
then if you add the H file to it they
just would have been too much for black
so look at this nature but this is
somebody needs to ask Jacques to
consider whether he whether he still
wants to win this match or not because
right now he's not playing the kind of
openings that are going to lead to
success against against the 2800 I mean
II 6 I could win this position as why
yes that did you even agree with that
tells you how bad this is for black
I mean party he said Bishop d3 the moves
aren't even hard to see if this no oh
thank you for that it's like when I get
a compliment from Picaro when he says
things like even you could win this
position yeah I wasn't meaning those are
my favorite anyway here comes Queen of
four I don't even know take a queen of
48 besides it's time it's time for shock
to wake up Anish is happy clearly should
be should be he's up six games into
three minute portion and I've never seen
anything like this honestly but I you
don't don't see if you play III in the
first we were h3 on the first moment you
know it's funny because we talk to
players
I love just please comment wondering is
it protesting something by playing FM
level yes you know I don't know it is
his fight for fight for FM like fight
for all fun masters out there I don't
know yep no it's no way it's so weird
because you know people play these
offbeat openings for fun yeah I want to
avoid serious when i play on my own it's
not that fun to get crushed by your no
winning is more fun than playing offbeat
openings I can tell you from personal
experience I think doing both
simultaneously is awesome so speaking of
fun Master fun master Mike the one and
only my client just told me he doesn't
want to be associated with this he said
even fun master doesn't play this
explicit --iv doesn't play definitely
you know what he says so not even fun
maps are happy with this one right now
wait do you see the name as opening I've
never heard of this before vant Avant
coach Avant crucial broken yah goatse
man you could have kids you're watching
sing that's what you said good don't you
have seen see more hello that minutes
ago yeah okay good
so I now see we've got singing with
hazel you know that yeah I know just
making sure so take on g6 after d5 so
black will play d5 here
take on g6 white is better because he
has control over the e-file but with the
Queen on d7 it means the rookie eights
gonna be totally fine and drop although
we've said draw up plenty of times
before and then here is one of those
games yeah you know I think this ran off
the rails early because of those games
you're highlighting it for those of you
just joining us 4,000 of you with us
thank you so much for being here a lot
it doesn't meant the early part of the
match Robin and I being vocal about our
criticisms of shock just not not
bringing his a game right now especially
in the first stage of things and Gary
punishing him but there were several
games in the early part of the match
that really came down to a time scramble
came down to some end game swindles and
at some point it seems like because he
wasn't playing troll openings the whole
time Robert he was playing more mainline
stuff earlier right so now he was and
that wasn't working out and this
certainly isn't working out I mean here
he's here he's not worse no it's not
worse than anything I just rinse and
repeat this thing no shock Bluffs on the
h-file
after TJ came from King f2 and then rook
h1 yeah where the yours of f6 is black
and okay yeah there was no threats but
yeah interesting okay well here we go
perhaps a mainline opening nope I spoke
too soon spoke too soon or c6 would have
been just fine there but I'm just gonna
save my voice for this Restless match
and let you you want me to take no
branson's don't want me to say anything
anyway it was being honest so you know
let's let's let you take over here and
talk make this an instructive lesson
welcome to a nice Geary's master class
unless Shakir chakri our Mahmud yarv
wants to turn things around because at
this point that's a c6 square and I'm
gonna put my pony on it tell everybody
how we win these positions as white you
put your knight on d4 you put your
bishop on e3 put your right foot you put
your bishop on the light squares and you
shake it all about 95 is even better
because not only
seven and you bring the matin bake look
at this
no oh go rook a7 Bishop III actually
just the most natural developing move
yeah the good name of the 95 is a can go
to b3 so like you know might be thirty
can be a bit of an annoying most
efficiently 373 night b3 rook a seven
and you shake it all about
gosh this is weird chess
I really have ever seen mounted jar of
in this sort of situation he's also I
guess not uh I didn't see Myers amazing
comment said I almost called chakra are
Shakira which is the level that he's
currently playing chess ad but by weight
let's not insult Shakira because who
knows maybe the Latin sensation can can
play yourself some mean chess I don't
know never ever compare Shakira to
anything negative just don't don't do it
word of advice for the Vice in front of
you anyway yeah yeah don't do that
wait ninety how many pawns is white up
Swan okay just one not the end of the
world but oh my god that's gonna be so
ruthless d6 the of h6 here maybe
still be six d6 Bishop e3 King H one
Bishop to e7 I think f7 with check I go
King f8 I'm back in 25 yeah I'm not
saying it's good I'm just saying I feel
like I might mate you anyway you know
Gary wants it look at him he's focused
in on a reason for a reason because he's
like oh he's gonna play this way your
admirers in the chat which is awkward
cuz he's also hanging out with me here
shout-out to our best friend John
Herschel who came through with this one
put the gun away
nothing like that needs to happen here
you're a goober goober yeah your group
Allah honks my gorg Gruber here we go
see I think I like Hans mice of the line
I wanted though here we go we're going
down I like the Geary's at least
bringing it so he has at least a draw
with Kingi
yeah live King g7 rook F says so he's
got it he's got a perpetual team wants
it
yeah Burke f7 King and by the way Bishop
check Bishop to c4 instead of v6 and
then on King e8 you move Queen f3 trying
to come and f7 Bishop's before I think
Bishop f5 might be a response I mean I
just oh I'll take the attack yeah I'm
with you I'm totally with you I mean
what a bishop things no Bishop g6 King
g7 I don't quite get there into deal but
so it's it's super I mean he's gonna
take his time figuring it out and we
respect that because you know we want
entertainment you know what other move
he could play here now he can't candy no
I can't
okay you can't never okay I thought
about a five but as you said Bishop a5
is just after King EA came by 95 somehow
I think he's just gonna settle he's
settling connect okay ah sticks out is
telling and discussed we feel the same
way on each Knight c3 first move I love
it I love it I love it
well this is gonna be a first the first
we've ever really seen the tilt happened
this early you know but I'm not even
sure what our argument was chess babe
but I'm sure I lost that's one thing
I've learned chess pays always right
just paid my wife two people can't get
around to Robert I don't know why I
thought I was me throwing is the third
but alright it's all good you're the
thing is like 70% of the time doesn't
count you're right most the time I'm not
gonna not give you that what do you want
for me you know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna dress this on air cut good I was
gonna say raised you know you're asking
me on everybody I'm not allowed to just
pay you in chess pieces anymore and get
a gift cards to Staunton House of chess
boards so I mean I'll take the chess
player that works it really was a sad
day for chests calm when Roberts stopped
accepting chuck-e-cheese coupons as
payment but you know he is he is only 15
so he's been working for us
she was 12 Miss Illinois we could keep
it legal we had to pay him in
chuck-e-cheese coupons awesome all right
so here here it's it's about as
normal-looking of structures we've had
in five games right you know an opening
this is Danny it's the Scandinavian yeah
where's where's JB Ames candy where's
John Bartholomew no one knows this is
the exact type of Skanda he likes I mean
I already butchered him yesterday so I
feel I don't feel bad but I feel like
I've just done it all already
I mean look at the position yep black
now at least I was the f6 square to use
fairly right no but this is like hi I'm
black I enjoy playing slightly worse
positions and getting grinded down in
log n games that's me like so Brooke d3
here for example Bishop f6 maybe we'll
go rook f3 and trying to sack my work
for you you wouldn't do something like
that yeah just felt like the time was
right no but okay the one way these
structures work out for black if we're
keeping an educational not just making
fun of team scandi who's not here to
defend himself
there's his army if black can get things
like c5 tactically you know safely
sometimes you can get counter play e5 is
really out of the question in this type
of position I think but with no minors
on the board that's the only thing
keeping white from just being winning
already right if you start adding
Knights you know on squares like efore
and f3 and you start giving white pieces
that can actually use all of this space
these types of positions are just so bad
for black but um okay the fact that
white doesn't have minors is the only
thing keeping blacks hopes alive at this
point right yeah and black looks
actually totally fine right now because
the d4 pawn is Queen g7 yeah yep there
there it is
and now c5 bye-bye bye-bye pawn you can
just can you can you just trade you
could have the thing is even the in-game
transition these days no fine for white
just because he has this three on two so
maybe this will be one of those weird
games that if if if Jacques accidentally
wins the game
do you think he's gonna start playing
good openings if he accidentally like
has a good chess game is he gonna like
pull it together here no no no I've kind
of given up on normal chess openings at
this point from he's got to play d5 now
no d5 hangs the bish bish one me Scylla
duh okay sorry um in fact what is he
gonna do to get out of that did he
some b-66 that mean attacks the rook but
then we just double six Queen a four
rook e to d8 and black is good yep
everyone's team's candy black finds a
way to win karma it's very very
frustrating yes karma is real this is
over she's a free pawn it's like when we
had self to the French yesterday and
then do this are winning with it that
was crazy
can we all just take a moment to
appreciate that young Kristoff dude I
just pulled the biggest upset and speech
has championship history that Robert
called amazing thank you amazing I feel
I feel good about that one even though
in my bracket I had cry every time we
had 200 for the for those who care about
the fantasy contest
there were 226 perfect brackets
remaining after due to beating karaoke
and there were 12 perfect brackets left
yep so okay what's going on in b4 he's
gonna try to get the c5 passer to
compensate for the deep one but Gary's
gonna trade everything on d4 and not
allow it kind of nice actually sub on c5
they should have to check do it bishop
f2 king takes Queen takes B - oh that's
who they might be King G - first that's
annoying
ah okay barely didn't Gary decides his D
pawn is stronger than anything to see
pawn can muster he'll blockade it and
he's probably right
Rippy 3ik over here on the on the
Batcave and see if we can analyze this
one but looks like black is is gonna
bring this D pawn home a little bit
faster than then Charlie over here on
the C file
this does not look good not at all feel
like I said that before I mean New York
trial of rook b7 which right now would
be quite timely but rook as ever D to c8
Queen f6 is even stronger you're
attacking c6 you're d4 it's well
protected all right well so rook c8 here
isn't gonna play Queen takes a 7 that's
somehow III gone for the mating attack
forget the rook on c7 oh he wins it
works he said oh he not acquainted to
king h1 does he win the rook back would
check somehow or he me to eat shoes good
you could almost even play Queen takes
g3 yeah can't be too bad but II to looks
you to look pretty good
I agree threatening to win you look back
the old-fashioned way
oh wait Queen f1 check we have one check
day he's got time to tickle always time
for a quick tickle yep now rugby 8 or be
able to do the trick rook b8 does the
trick by the way everyone because if
rook d7 you can even just trade then
Queen of three and pick up the pond
I was gonna swing my work back to ye
after that but yeah you're right Queen
f3 also picks that bond I know but
you're right but I think rook d7 rookie
8 is stronger yeah just gonna meet Oh
what of all the moolah that's enough
wait this is like the worst wing I was
literally just turned the game from a
win for black into something where black
may have to bail out with a perpetual
check because rook e8 and getting a
queen oh my gosh yeah that was enough
that was not the way to do this Gary
knows he's safe with a perpetual at any
time but there's no way
black wasn't winning here Brooks e8
there was that a mouse lit or was that
no I think I think he just I think he
missed his chance he uh I mean it's a
very strange yes I agree
uh kind of curious I mean it's not
really a turning point in the matter
baby was not worth asking the interview
but what
I have no idea yeah it's called a
Brooklyn variation what ie
I was gonna say we're Brooklyn AB this
offensive debris don't give them a good
don't call them out jay-z you'll have
your head I'm look I'm literally
googling this right now
Brooklyn variation chess what is this
the oken defense Brooklyn Vic how do yo
can in Brooklyn go hand in hand here
anyway this looks okay white just has
another comfortable edge the bishop on
g2 super dominant peace and an open
center like this the bishop on c8 will
be forever struggling and look at that
that's the brute force way to to flex
the muscles of the bishop on g2 just go
threaten a sex yeah but these are the
kind of positions they don't really
deceptively dangerous where you think
it's simple but your lack of development
because of the constantly possible
tactics or really make black much worse
here what do you say I just found out
why it's called the Brooklyn bouquet and
it's not because Maurice Ashley okay
it's because Joel Benjamin this is a
favorite of Joel Benjamin a pet line
really and he is from Brooklyn Alvin's
defense Brooklyn variation because of
Jill Benjamin at least you can leave
today saying Jacque tried to destroy the
troll he trolled with chess but we
learned something no matter what so that
I'm upset honestly okay for this
position trying to get back to the
chassis just take up six and play rook a
four and then you know I'll black out
for a little bit how was work a foragers
not super delicious here delicioso Dora
speaking of which doesn't the winner of
this match go on to play Diego himself
from Dior Oh Dora the Explorer Wesley so
I know the winner this goes on to play
Levon Aronian
vodka gotcha Go Diego Go we'll have to
wait a little bit longer to see Wesley
so play again
Queen age five hear anything about a
pleasure before Queen c4 and your
Knights not really doing very well
c3 was really not the best move I don't
understand why broke a four couldn't
have been couldn't have been played but
alright blacks I'm doing yeah all the
sudden the bishops are
coming out efore isn't he played play it
or just looks good well eat for might be
event by g4 so that kind of scares huh
undermining the central part is a very
interesting theme when you when your
point is double F pawns playing a move
like g4 it seems counterintuitive your
underling their pawns but sure but often
times yeah and you're prying open the
the light squares to go at that King in
the process so yeah II for now looks
very tempting as well but II for G for
goat III just say enjoy my EEP on I'll
take your Jeep on and you'll be stuck
with a weirdo on oh it feels like a do
plastic with a weirdo you know they you
know things got weird that night alright
let's say that Wow yeah okay the a pawn
Falls but that means b7 is going with it
what's he gonna do if Bishop takes is
gonna play e4 and trap the trap the
bishop outside the pawn chain
this looks just great for black I'm
missing something probably but I mean
Bishop d7 or Queen b6 + f2 Falls could
be sevens also under attack Peter Nelson
we promised not to talk about that night
Danny you're right I fall Ben alright
well he decides that's not worth going
after the pawn
Anish nursing his his advantage here
again when you're up six games you might
I don't know I think it's the right
decision anyway because if the rooks
come off suddenly you start to realize
just how weak this f5 pawn is right
white plays Knight e3 Bishop h3 I don't
really know that white isn't any danger
of losing this game yeah I mean an extra
point against a pawn I can he just taken
on f2 that's what I've been trying to
get it Daniel
you just call me Daniel I did you just
didn't you young man yield me and this
looks pretty awesome for black I mean
just you now you're up to pawns so
you're gonna have to take them be seven
or else all right you could play Queen
d6 there I guess now I want to eat four
though I just want to say no more to
your Bishop coming back and guarding
things but queen bee five hits b2 and b7
it's a fork
I like oh he likes it too and you know
big problem for whitey stick I move a
queen da Czech king of seventh Queen c7
check I was a king to g6 my king is safe
over there I'm threatening Bishop d5
because the king is in mate if I can get
another checking so this should have
three inviting me for let's check but
the point is there a for Queen da check
you know longer if king of seven because
Queen B sure eats five check so King G
sounds very useful disciplined you can't
can't move this Queen from d1 because
the f1 Knight is hanging I I don't want
to speak too soon but I feel like we're
about to get a win here for for shock
wait it wasn't a for just winning on the
spot instead of Bishop e7 yeah II for
Bishop g2 III Bishop f 3e to Bishop
takes you to Queen takes you to Queens
at Bishop e5 checkmate on the diagonal
so that would've been this nasty so
nasty I have to show it on the analysis
board because that would have been
shaken what your mama gave you okay I
think I think shock gets this game
anyway but that you're right driving the
e pawn there would have been nasty yep
okay and now he's gonna take before he
still still how many pawns is yet enough
actually he's only up one no - no - oh
it looks like four it looks like a lot
more than it is you're right he's just
gonna get the ladies off the board and
make it easy Bishop e3 threatening Queen
c1
yeah this is once the Queen's get traded
the extra two ponds and the a pond is
just very simple like so then it'll
become a five-point match feel like I'm
talking about a DNA it's a five-point
match yeah we have we have the right
suspect I was a c7 okay the bishop
covers that's where you are all over the
map that is my point match DNA man you
take it yeah you've been watching CSI
New York again I know where you're going
with things half the time today
Bishop d5 check now don't go Bishop b5
because it releases protection the c8
squared wait what did he want to check
mom Mira's blundering this game away so
we thought he would win this game how
did he not win this game what in the
world everything is going wrong for him
oh my gosh Queen h6 here is that yes
can't get too aggressive here but but
this really is a shocker now he's now
he's taking the Queen's off the board
which right he's King can't move so like
yeah I mean there's a giri going after
the bishop I would have just walked the
king up but what's he doing he's just
gonna sit on the position no he wants to
come back
luckily for shock take a ship is the
wrong color yeah the bishop is the wrong
color so all he has to do is just March
the H pawn up and it's a draw yep he
found it h4 whoa that is he tall he is
his um what's that called on not pre
move the other thing click to move no
one only when you we touch a piece of
ahi is illegal moves only on okay it's
still gonna be a draw but this should
not happen I don't think I should have
been a draw by that point maybe it
already mr. sillens wrong Wow Wow Gary
takes a big sigh of relief yeah that's
what happens when you have Lee you know
if it's it's the only legal move if you
touch your piece it plays it good
good if you're in a crazy time scramble
bad if well bad if you touch the wrong
piece frankly that was that was a that
was not good yeah that that was crazy so
four straight draws but they've not been
you know peaceful game that even
anything but and Mahmoud Arab missed an
opportunity get himself back in this
match and with those four straight draws
that's well guess are there only four
told draws and ten and a half went
pretty crazy so there are only four
draws total yesterday
cardiac I didn't do to really bring in
bring in to the decisive chess just with
the white pieces every single game was a
victory don't look now I almost feel
like I see a normal opening yeah I mean
not not on a bite for white necessarily
but a small edge nonetheless were for
momager over here it started with d4 but
it looks like it came out of an exchange
Carrick on now that sounded like the
start to like a horror movie it started
with d4 so white just pushing pawns
there's no real attack these are getting
treated but actually maybe you can start
playing f4 g4 and you gotta do something
sorry I have to say
smelly socks double-oh-seven who's
normally here to do nothing Patrol us
gave me give me one thing to laugh at he
said Gary's rap name is 50% yeah that's
the oldest isn't really I've never heard
it I thought it was hilarious
no go back to trolling sunny socks
you tricked me into thinking you're
being original it's not your fault look
at general Castro saying more like Josh
Kim you know that's uh never heard that
one but I don't like it as much
unfortunately
oh man Miguel Rodriguez made a donation
earlier he's a diamond member in the
Chad there too thank you for that it had
nothing but compliments for us so I
didn't want to read it on air okay
that's good yeah Thank You Miguel
especially as we devolve into just
nonsense
I mean it's it's kind of hard Danny
because yesterday we had this great
match with an epic upset and like you're
so close to rout and now on smash where
it feels that you know even in games
your mom and Jared was playing better or
winning it's just like all Geary a
hundred things but just super surprising
given that I had this date circled on my
calendar you know I felt like this was
one of those weird ones where the
seeding worked out being based on chests
calm ratings the giri was one of the
higher seeds and shock we are not having
played as much on chess calm was lower
but right now it's looking like maybe it
wasn't an accident so yep but okay match
is not over we have seen four and five
game comebacks before in this format we
really have and I'm on Hamilton earlier
in the twitch chat said maybe he'll run
out of so many bad openings to play that
in the bullet chest he'll actually start
playing good openings and who knows
maybe he'll mount to come back so tough
to see that especially as the leanest
six games I haven't seen wait Somalia
was one one game right or two how many
enemies won't you gotcha
- and I think that would be five draws
right yeah I think feels like the last
time he won is the same time his like
background was made like 1960 well what
is going on there that movie cape faints
right they pay a lot of money in
Hollywood to get cameras to look like
that to get get that kind of effect if
you look closely you'll see like Jack
from lost just quickly flicker across
the screen and a flashback it's pretty
awesome on this another draw Gary's uh
like we said taken at home why don't I
have a Lionel Richie emote oh wait no
that's uh that's cool story Bob I
thought that was Lionel Richie that's
the that's Bob the artist guy I'm gonna
get a Lionel Richie emote combined
somehow with the chief or emote because
Lionel Richie if I would guess knew how
to play chief or that's all
as this where you say oh boy your emote
no I chose not to say oh boy this I'm
just keeping myself by smarter chest
that there's only been one win for
momager ah okay I was wrong
sorry oh yeah wishful thinking this
opening looks pretty normal
he's laid before night of 698 so I'm
it's good you said the opening was
pretty normal and I about yell over the
position looks relatively knowing the
fact that well I kind of gone Knight f6
to g8 and back to f6 might have cost a
couple Tempe that might be important to
a position like it's an imposition like
this white has complete control over the
center and this is why black makes us
break but look at the pawn structure now
a 6b 7 d5 compared to this nice pollen
chain a through the C files the d5 pawn
clear target isolated white can try to
play for c6 it's a moment saying that
I'm going to leave you with an isolate a
pawn as well and I actually like the
idea with c6 just to like I said to give
black another weakness in the position
and here Bishop before is a good
decision find black trying to get rid of
this weakness but Y can play rook e1 and
and if everything gets traded white
takes on e8 with Chuck at some point I
mean sorry takes on this where you take
with the Brooke obviously okay he's no
Queen D for now yep get the other rook
on the action you're not taking the bait
right mamakara plays Knight f6 Knight g8
and he's just you know gonna get an edge
and and let let's shock suffer so now
he'll be playing for two results for the
what will likely be the remainder of the
three-minute portion here no not quite
more time for this lifeline that rookie
for Queen d5 rook e1 check has to be
careful so you didn't take with the rope
but they said almost a blunder there and
talked about heads going opposite
directions we thought we saw it
yesterday with a huge upset
young Christoph judah's emo being way on
top but here you see Giri sort of
looking down upon mama Gaurav and his
openings I would say yeah it's really
kind of a mesmerizing graph I found
myself just you know looking at the odds
there here is so close to a hundred
percent he's too close to the Sun mama
Gaurav right oh did you just go Ikaros
yeah yeah way to drop the Icarus
reference Greek mythology combined with
modern mythology of Broadway Hamilton
Thank You linman lin-manuel Miranda
Hamilton was so good don't remind me
again that you've seen it I haven't
you've done that like seven times I told
you last week not to do that I'm sorry I
was in Vegas what happens in Vegas
should stay in Vegas except for Hamilton
that is so good that has to come back
with you you know anyway they didn't go
man I just my wife my wife your mom gets
mad at me my wife falls more in love
with you every show we do so she walks
around singing Hamilton all the time
love Hamilton all right Brooke endings
there for kids bring the Brooke to b3
take with the King on f3 draw tune yep
three on three but just you know the
pawns for black look very nice and that
pawn chain the good thing having an
outside past pawn though is it can be
used as a decoy they never play yeah
there's gonna be if it was a King and
pawn ending this pawn chases the King
away in white wins but rook and pawn
endings are drawn and the match
continues 18 minutes left we might be on
pace for one of the the most games
played in a match I'm sure that my
client is already all over that stat but
with with how many how many draws have
we had here very quick draws at times
too many said their answer yep
I feel like I passed that one any we got
f4 taking one out of Sasha griffix book
okra Shooks book like that
rolls off very naturally very shortly in
the 8th round I want to say of the
Sinquefield Cup against Wesley so yeah
but f-for in the first move something
you don't see very often at such a high
level but he said it's a kind of a
secret weapon
and Mike doesn't think we'll be close
I'm not sure he's right though because
Jacques also I mean I can think of three
games where Mahmoud guard resigns super
early
yeah there's no 17 minutes left of this
portion so lots of time left
yep what's a for coming a 495 is it not
yep
before 95 95 maybe nuts other than
Bishop h6 likes Maui I just I started to
say Danny no matter where is the Queen
away Gary Gary plays a6 at some point
here you might want to look for a five
you forcefully probably open the dark
squares now you got to go back and that
was kind of like a Catalan where white
plays d3 incident d4 huh so not as good
white plays d3 d4 uncle your mom once
told me that's why he never liked any of
the e3 lines against the Kings Indian
because all white wants to do after
playing e3 is play Eve 4 so that's
actually that's fair and I trust in
Yermo I trust by the way the record
amount of games just Carlsen so with 37
games and we're on pace for thorough
okay got it
that's what you're saying is there's a
chance no no I hear you Mary Queen a5
Bishop see Celine 85 you wanna bet no oh
oh man that'll teach you do we should we
be surprised that I'm right I think we
know if I was better so we should be
surprised
oh goodness blunder oh he just wanted a
piece oh my god he's just laughing and
shaking it off he's like oh man just not
my day
so you were right no mc6 buddy yeah cuz
neither force be three and then you
would take on a four so this is one of
those moments where you know and they
can open tournament you just withdraw
and you like crying I bet he just asked
his manager my loader withdrawal from
this and he'd be like no shock we signed
a contract you got to play all the games
there is no forfeiting the match
although you know Europeans are much
less likely to withdraw because they
don't do that in your right and even in
open term it's not a common practice in
the u.s. much more so no but I mean I
guess the nature of this match I mean
it's it it's much more lopsided so I'm
not gonna sit here and try to pretend
like either one of us saw this coming
but these sort of things can happen when
like we say in a European tournament but
at least they have a rest day or
sometime to have gather their thoughts
and emotions after they play like like
Duda you know and no nothing on that
reference okay no your Monday and they
have nothing they have nothing to do -
it could to calm themselves to refresh I
mean that's why these things are you
know are really tough so speaking of
really tough mom and Jaros position in
this game is tough uh he's got some
compensation for the Queen he's gonna
play night before how do you gar see -
uh-uh did he did he trick - Gary trick
himself really well he just put his face
in his hand way his Queens trapped like
where's the Queen go and go to e1 that's
what I thought and then yeah yeah but
now night before and you have to move
your bishop I guess you just give up the
rook yeah but that's terrible I mean
yeah you're right though and just looks
I just looked turned in my head for the
first time to see and you saw I was in
this room well no I just saw a queen was
happening though okay so this is plain I
see - take C - firms and then take g5
likely yeah this move ward is better I
think
this looks very bad for Geary 95 92
Queen moves I take your rook you take me
back to rooks are better than a queen
especially in position like this wise
words where like where blacks king is
safe you want the Queen when there's an
unsafe King but with a very safe King
the Taurus is just dominant so yeah
should be straightforward the Queen
needs open Kings or pawn weaknesses on
both sides of the board to be able to to
bounce around and keep the rooks from
coordinating this is this is a close
enough Center King safe and really only
one or two open files means the Brooks
are really gonna dominate Gary might
resign here you really think so
you might means position is very lost
but Jacques took g5 first instead of
taking c2 he could now he can save the
rook instead of taking back on g5
perhaps there's nowhere to say the rook
because if they wrote me 191 eirick d1
yeah but then I have two pieces in a
rook for a queen which is still I had no
I agree what's he doing with east six
seven would also encourage you to resign
I could come back just castles you know
yeah she just saved the bishop you're
right get the bishop to safety no Castle
is also very good we got a hundred bits
just now from OMG Bentley wants the shot
come back oMG asked him Marty if he
starts winning games and you keep
donating will let him know who was
behind him secret sponsor Bentley
they'll sponsor Bentley Mahmoud Yaris
brought to you by Bentley Lowe's let's
build something together this game just
just you can even take the pawn but
Bishop e7 looks perfectly good castling
looks very good he's taking a lot of
time here I mean I know it's kind of
making me nervous
they both see something that we don't he
decides to take c2 but here comes Queen
e5 Bishop g7 can't be a bad move here
there it is yep good enough I guess but
I can save the rook and material count
is 1 to 4 minor pieces in a row so
you're broken to pieces for a queen and
now before cam nice move so what is
gonna take on e4 position deep and all
serious though seriousness though to
keep it instructive we should appreciate
Gary's movie 6 regardless of whether
white gets anything here because we talk
about material not being as important as
the actual ability to make threats when
you have these unbalanced situations a
queen versus a bunch of pieces
so Gary recognizing his practical
situation the best thing he could do was
to try to mix it up maybe create some
attacking chances against the king and
it likely doesn't work out if black
plays the best moves but now that the
position has become a little more
dynamic the Queen does have things to
poke at right she's got she's got
weaknesses on both sides of the board
the King isn't completely safe so again
like I don't get me wrong all right I
mean black should be winning even on 96
but this is again this is a great moment
where we can highlight the instructive
part of Queen to c4 you would much
rather have less material in terms of
the points dr. evil quotation fingers
but keep the initiative in an unbalanced
material situation then you would settle
on material so here I would not be
surprised if he doesn't take the rook
exactly you have to find some way for
counter play this is how you play these
positions so even if Gary loses you
would agree partner sorry I talk too
much there but wanted to drive them away
come on I'm at a hundred percent
agreement because taking the material
there was answering a losing position
here at least mommy Jarvis lots of proof
and his King is on f6 who wants to know
six like this but rook you want so you
should be winning and it looks like mama
Jarrah played well too to kind of parry
the threats of the Queen but from a
practical perspective we can learn
something from that cuz I mean I know
you and I both at games we're like you
end up doing that right you you
recognized
that you're worse and you do that in
sometimes your opponent doesn't play the
right defense and you do come back and
win right so absolutely another another
thousand bits just donated for Geary
though so a bidding war
a hundred bits for a shock and who was
that blank wins says I got your back
Geary don't worry about it
but shot gets a win a much-needed one
and he's only down by six Robert I
forgot it got to seven I was thought
that that cut to five but now that you
you know pointed the score is Clouseau
it's six and if that's the case more
problems
oh yeah the game before you'd blown it
apiece so no I mean what mommy drove
really needs to do is just cut it down
to four to have any sort of prayer but
yeah it's not happening this is a decent
position though because you look at the
structure you see that it has many
qualities of the Grune field except for
the fact that Bishop is on e7 rather
than she said right so black isn't
poking at the center in the same lip and
in doing so white has the stronger
center because there's a Diani pawn
versus justinep on for black now in an
endgame in which were you know maybe a
sort of sim you have an A and B pawn for
black Justin a pawn for whites there's
the outside past pasta chewy which
sounds good but in practice it's
actually very difficult to get those
pawns moving because if one of those key
pawns get traded as if you have a target
isolated exactly as I said upon a bishop
before is a nice move except for k-6
because if you move you're backwards and
black plus a five that pawn if something
it's so isolated technically but with a
bishop protecting a pawn like that it
doesn't feel isolated now he just feels
like a big problem because after work a
six Queen a sixth a seventh directive
threat and you're gonna have to defend a
pond unending frankly the most mainline
most instructive game we've seen shocked
play yet honestly and who what was the
matter you and I saw a whole bunch of
this right was the MBL Dominguez Perez
man yep for those who watch every speed
chess match you know that we talked a
lot about the
structure and Roberts instructive points
there about the queenside majority
majority versus at becoming targets I
can't say words today man I'm tripping
over my own tongue you know you're
saying ideas and that's better than
worlds there's somebody write that down
that was deep deep it's just like chess
is not a game of moves to game of plans
right so just waiting where's that
Bishop going uh if it goes to g6 i4q emo
and then Eve night no you don't NT v is
pawn takes d6 hits the Queen's over here
Bishop c3 just in the nick of time of
rook d7 rook d7 maybe cuz the pawn on d4
actually is not easy to defend Queen C
for Queen C for his leadership in
defense at right yeah he likes it this
is bishops trapped
come on shock queen a theory though only
move whoa what in the world
no this doesn't work pawn takes d5 pawn
defy solution changes Ryan's piece yeah
that is not a tactic that will save you
here and why couldn't he play Bishop a5
alright probably could all right look at
it look at everybody's Abi's bouncing
around that's two games in a row let's
go go come back Joe Cole to come back
opinion for years
sorry that was awesome
yo L tell you you didn't the opposite of
the Serena Williams commercial David
showing with a baby and then what a
major like 9 months later she's a
monster
no she's amazing obviously mushy have
you seen the commercial and she like she
whispers it
she's like today don't call it a
comeback right no I love it I never left
I love it yeah no it's great and Jacques
I mean in all seriousness he wins
another game were in that we're in the
distance where historically it has been
done before if he's only down by four
games we have seen people overcome four
game deficits to win the match in the
final portion and
whoever was donating bits to shock you
better keep it up cuz he won two in a
row since you started
I forget the username my B and usually
says he just gave him a head start
that's all game a head start right let's
see okay he is playing main line opening
- I said if he wins a couple games is he
gonna is he gonna wake up and stop
throwing a tantrum and start playing
good chess with this troll Hopa things I
mean now he's doing it and his position
is quite decent with the black side here
because this configuration with GG pawns
it seems like a weakness or we don't
like having double pawn right but
actually sometimes doubled pawns really
protect our game and also helps
protected men in a dive so there's no
recovery there and look at black that's
better here honestly this is a minority
attack where the pieces are right where
they need to be to expose weaknesses
White's gonna try to get c4 to get rid
of that weak C pawn but yeah and this
move Bishop d6 helps play e5 for black
also you can think about but probably
should not do put them upon f5 and that
way f4 can come after and c4 is a good
idea
Queen geez I like this you know you
don't mind both sides having an isolated
pawn here because the Queen now has
access to the King side V&G foursquare
don't play it yet with the Romantics
hang right
well actually queen g4 is interesting
because you can sack on g3 trying to
figure out the right configuration if I
go Bishop d3 prodigy to Queen g4 you
have to go Bishop f2 I think yeah
because you're threatening oh maybe
maybe you can ignore it and play Brooke
takes c6 give me three would check yeah
yeah you're I say check only no Aslam
bow and just go out the way oh man look
at you busting out the Dani wrench okay
well he's definitely gonna be
calculating it it seems unnecessary I
mean there are other moves for black
here I mean just put your rook on the C
file to guard c6 right or move the
knight and now now come to g4 and maybe
even bring the other Knight to f5 so
still feels like Jacques
feeling better right now and very good
chance this will be the last game in the
three-minute and so if it's a win we've
we've set the stage with three games in
a row a four take a four more and then
don't call it a comeback 95 didn't seem
ideal I didn't like Bishop takes d5 I
thought he could take it on a four right
away but Brooke before is it a good move
because it's axe a for any good swing
that rook to the kingside I see fine
that's a good move because now he can
play just simple moves right like Queen
d2 Queen of three okay yeah get the
Queen's off the board so if Queen Nathan
came after the knight c6 you have Bishop
d2 coming after what shelf work is now
the a pawn is a target a5 that's very
true
very very unfortunately true for black
okay no Queen f3 king of three knight c6
Bishop B's whoever beats who there may
be I please d4 right away so what's
going on here Bishop David rival rooks
on the second rank I have a 95 Bishop
takes a5 Knight to d5 and he had to do
this cuz g4 was actually in danger of
trapping that night on h5g 4g4 well you
know he kicked the ball has to
give the f4 square back there's a 95
here looks I do Oh a 95 no it doesn't
hang on I get it made out of - it's an
egg d5 huh
he's on I see sex enjoy taking five
so what now okay - like I was like
thinking a guy out of ideas it's the
mission once it sounds very strong yeah
somehow Gary got in like a thief in the
night stole the pawn I mean you even 93
here feels feel solid over a protectee
five overprotective to attack the knight
on c6 threatened g4 imagine what went
wrong here for mom a jar of I think
everything yeah that means seem like I'm
not sure I love this decision to take
that many five if I think I've won Queen
takes a four and that was just a pawn
after move 2595 they've officially
informed the players that this is their
last game of the three minute portion so
don't go anywhere everyone if the
comeback is is meant to be it's gonna
have to happen in Bullitt especially cuz
it looks like this last minute game is
actually not gonna go be a series way he
can't be thrilled with how this is
happening
said night a five okay so isn't that an
H five at least can come back to the
game but this is not I've avoided making
fun of the ambulance as we here outside
your window all day but it looks like
hotel medics this is actually a
first-time viewer because he just
guessed that you were in New York and I
think everybody knows that by now so
it's a welcome hotel
welcome hotel I like that you see the
hotel suppose and welcome you hey that's
that's how great we are here on Twitch
ninety-two check 9400 play is on f2 is
falling and d6 is hanging yeah that was
a blunder Geary not the way whoa boy
he's just gonna reboot I think he just
forgot I think he was focused on f2 and
just forgot that Bishop was hanging and
if this ends will be a four-point match
if Zen's yeah as it seen if forgive to
rook at 5:05 midnight hangs anyway so
it's not over over oh but he gets that
have six Wow Gary just collapsed in that
game whoa why do you take the rook
I mean he's so probably would even why
do you think the rook under seven that
was crazy
that was efficient with only ten seconds
okay now he's like asking did not win
this game it is winning but if one more
pawn Falls meaning the g7 pawn it's not
a win especially with no time I would
just play up six here yeah hi g4 very
nice very key actually it's gonna be
enough likely for shock to get this one
now he goes into gathers up the a pawn
Knight c7 is gonna be played and I see
seven forks ville and now it's just
ninety five coming next just winning
trade so it's a fork game we yeah that's
to the shock of the world no pun
intended
given that our man at chakra our mama
Gaurav is the one who just pulled that
off but we're gonna give the players a
quick break and we're gonna be right
back because guess what Robert guess
what what
we have a match that was the four I'd
win in a row Mahmoud Yara if you're just
joining us was down by seven games he's
one of the last four games I'm am
impressed by his resolve and his ability
to come back therefore wait three three
in a row or four in a row dude he was
down by seven games and now he's down by
four
that's three you know I can't do math
but we're gonna be right back
yeah don't go anywhere and we have a
match despite what we were seeing
earlier I'm gonna guess we do see some
mainline openings from Mahmoud Garvin
bullet and we'll see if Geary can hold
on well your life
[Laughter]
sorry well kid I said I knew I was live
no but that was awesome
um it's okay to admit that you get
annoyed by comments because we know you
get annoyed by my comments tell you what
I haven't been annoyed by the fact that
this match just got close and we are not
gonna be sitting here talking about fun
ways to win in a plus eight plus
whatever match not to say that those
rooting for a nice giri shouldn't
continue to root for him but at this
point mahmoud yaar has shown us that
he's not going anywhere and I believe
the match is beginning checking out the
players are ready there you go we had
other donut we had more donations while
I was gone
$20 motivation for shock from Bruno
himself as that Sacha Baron Cohen or
Peru knows that Sacha Baron Cohen in the
chat are you just happy to see me well
who B juvies here and says that he's
happy to see me so let's let's check out
how his boats gonna go and both sides
playing instantly I let's see this is
the type of game you want and boy well H
full G and this isn't yeah this isn't
crazy aggressive chest this is a type of
structure that's easy to attack with a
relatively close center and an
accelerated attack based on the fact
that you know black has black has no
knight on the Kings side there you know
so there's vulnerability to the lack of
minor piece defense you're already
looking at ways to just blow things open
[Music]
Gary Gary needs to stop the bleeding and
and get a win yep and he well he's kind
of prevented the attack here or at least
mom and Europe didn't get more of an
attack because it looked like he would
and this f5 squares in this night
regrets up to e7 is going to be a very
good one for that night and so g6 I
guess Knight wants to come to h2 at some
point yeah alright sorry I went meant to
f6 but I thought you know 3 h2 of course
going to e5 is way better to the knight
f6 check alright so I need to get my
queen on the diagonal I don't want to
see a way to do that so he just protects
his second ring and so Queen C 1 here
looks like oh don't like a 3 this is not
going the direction the white wants we
talked about the King side attack but
but now we have overextended and a
potentially weak King he's trying to go
for Knight things defy that's what he'd
played it like this wait Knight 6585
Queen B - look at that tactic he missed
it over 95 this Queen b7 whom idea was
there 95 pawn to Queen you were willing
to work with the back rank yeah I guess
it still might not have worked out but
it looked very tempting so I got excited
now I'm gonna calm myself down we're
allowed to get excited this looks very
difficult for both sides like a 3 yeah
it's hard to tell who's gonna get made
it here right you've got white and a lot
more danger than he was when the center
was closed but this King this King old
boy right right so rookie 3 we're eating
with a vile motif I didn't want to get
my rep in look so I thought I was
essentially you know training right here
and takes d6 now you were yep not any
more
but still there's oh okay there has to
be something every Queen I thought we
were gonna see Queen e5 and I thought it
was a double a 94 94 I thought was a
Queen d6 now for black 26 get the ladies
off but still if this rook can just find
an open file here country rook back
now a knife Nordine f7 is so huge this
is winning for Gary Gary's gonna get
there in this night is in one of those
really bad positions highlighting that
they are not the best pieces of stopping
passed pawns frustrating for momma gr
but okay only five games if your giri or
in Gary's camp you're happy to see him
rebound and not going on a massive
losing streak to end the day but yep
and that was I you know I'd like the
opening and looked very double-edged and
that's just what you want when you're
trying to win games I see Kiryas
internet connection just went down to
one yeah something happened there okay
he's back
lagging a little bit bad Anish bad
matter - bad yeah here is a very solid
setup for white and would you if your
Anish you kind of want to have long
bullet games that one second increment
means that the games can last quite
right
well we're not gonna get a long bullet
game here or we might but we're not
getting a trying to milk the clock what
we're trying to get as a wait reckless
attack no 96 gets you made it I guess
yeah
actually maybe six if you play might be
six the bishop might have even just
fallen back to d3 right yeah rookie
three the Brooks swinging over even to
g3 so he's a choice tonight f5 and then
GC looks looks good he'll meet rook g3
get from Knight f5 it's sort of his last
time yeah even now there's other tactics
coming
perhaps on e6 with the g6 yep he sees it
captures he can even just retreat and
he's got plenty of pawns for the piece
yeah he does but again one of those
positions where all of a sudden black is
out of it now you have four minor pieces
that's who's hanging c5 hanging I'm
starting like black sugar the minors are
just so much more useful in these types
of fast time controls - there's just so
many tricks
yep and okay queen d5 she's offering to
trade because he's this past a pawn and
this past beep on both of which are
start about to start roaming free and
the bishop on b2 is extra and g7 is so
strong covering in the entire length and
diagonal for measuring d3 Bishop best to
come back to f1
yep yeah it's but this this game is uh
he missed Bishop f3 before take Gandhi
to that would've oh wow tactic nasty it
looks like in this way she just blows
probably Knight takes e5 ok URI a little
perplexed by that decision to a5 a4
still is still enough yeah but a little
bit strange technique there wait a
second take on b3 not winning for black
that's what yeah then you need to win
games like this can't afford to draw
with bringing down this many points okay
ok f5 check is a admission of the
mission of a draw might as well just in
it if your Giri you do the thing yep
just keep playing never offer a draw
no he's not not doing that but could've
could have could have gone Grichuk right
get a Gumby
yeah exactly the so what 2023 plus
minutes left 5 game lead ok still so
Kumasi pasa still mathematically in
range and playing not necessarily back
to the openings we saw for the majority
of the three-minute portion but
definitely an obscure approach here
hoping for mate there you go not gonna
let him mate over the 7 oh darn
so Y can go h4 following Knight g5
instead of d3 I probably would've
started with Adria okay but black is
good I think constructive fee and keto
by hand
but like d3 was a wasted move you should
have just gone to h4 right away
you wasted a very important move there
he still has long term attacking chances
though he can put the bishop on h6 okay
or g5 get castled and and this is not an
easy position for Geary to defend at all
that's true Queen h4 I forced him to
take on g5 it's Oh doesn't freaking move
is he gonna meet Knight d4 would take g5
mm maybe I don't like that though cuz
then he'd take on e6 take on g6 he does
it because it prevents castles long
that's what I was thinking
Queen age three hitties oh he needs me
there was Queen e7 right it wasn't you
have an N queen eh a check of acacia
yeah but look at these pawns are both
hilarious and just strong in the center
the box of pollens hunt I don't think I
know this is awesome right take a
picture with your face camera I really
really have ever seen that before
now the queen is inching her way in I
think that I think that Gary has his
work cut out for him to hold this one
especially given that he's already down
this much on the clock yeah he's up on
rate is yeah I can't count with four
pawns we forgot to you know that it was
the Frankenstein Dracula opening fund
Master Mike about had a hissy fit and
every other chest kid in the world so
this is I mean black can't be doing
badly here a pawn has the I see in a
game chat Frank Andy
Tim Johnson goes gary taking center
control a bit too soon
that's pretty funny now it just doesn't
get as King mated but know it like this
is this is so frustrating it oh but the
bishops trapped gonna say it's
frustrating if your mob a jar of because
you're running out of diagonals for the
Queen as long as the center remain
closed but he finds he finds relief in
the form of a trap Bishop I say he
didn't take on d6 when he could have but
he's taking all the Queen side pawns
king f4 is generally speaking not the
move you really want to play when you're
Bishop and your problems with the Queen
on the Queen side it's a queen Ephesus
please look okay just not enough time
Queen f3 yep yeah also Mahmud your play
this one really yeah no seriously this
is what he needs to do right get back to
trusting his his intuition play some
normal openings for the love of all that
is holy and McGarry if he could mount
here Arthur
what do you you're smart to play on a
little yeah yeah I get a little bit of
time off the total match clock so four
game deficit all right all right Mahmud
jarv I see you right now see you baby
you know I like I was not impressed by
his bullet skills before the match he
was losing some games to a Shrek dahveed
or strike David probably struck that B
and you know what it wasn't uplifting to
see that but right now especially with
the increment things perhaps can turn
his way right we saw this in the first
game of the match right was it that
early but much more aggressive here from
black and this is one that has already
backfired a little bit I think yeah this
is already just a bad move order for
white Bishop h6 you can trade and then
you could defend and then well yep with
other night so Bishop h6 clean this
works together
I just wanna distract the Queen from the
protection the F to square but in many
ways he's smart to force this without
laying the Queen come at 8-6 first right
so the King backs up and the point is
that a lot of these positions flip
around and black is the one with the
attack here very quickly
although Knight f4 was strong as have
Knight G Fox Bishop c4 check might have
been devastating oh wow it may still
come he finds it what a nice shot
so wait what Bishop c4 others Knight d5
knight of seven when I have 719 g6 whoa
okay say put that any six and saying if
you trade on e6 but now no Queen g7 okay
that looks like a good defensive
resource wait Queen Knight takes f8 here
yeah White's getting enough well now
take on a tan out bikini seven I don't
know if White's getting enough after all
Bishop d7 yep rook a six
I meant enough in terms of the
compensation that the attack didn't have
to win because here I mean he's not
really in danger of losing this ending
just too many pawns have fallen yeah
although if black is quick to win this
f2 pond then it can be truncated he
might just take a draw and be happy with
the overall match situation but why did
get enough that you didn't have to check
me that's I mean it's kind of a loss
every time you don't get a win at this
boys for mama drive it should 57 but
okay like I mean objectively you're
playing on with the two pieces because
the math situation objectively White's
not worse here I don't know about that
okay I mean f4f 3e4 just trade this IDC
check 92 taken up three now it's bad f3
was bad f4 was was better yeah I agree
no I mean III think you're right that
like you know if you think about this in
a long-term and just look at the board
it looked like what was doing okay but
well even here I mean the dude this is
okay yeah I agree I mean an end Gary
blundered with this move f3 but came
closer than but this is the kind of
situation where the rook should be fine
against the miners cuz he already had
enough passed pawns and and he may still
be fine it's a Bishop d7 on King III yep
he just got out of it
Nietzsche Oh Bishop g4 instead of Bishop
e7 was much stronger clearly but this is
a you know the sad part about this Dany
is he spent sign of time from a match
perspective it's rough rough when you're
not getting this win here poor shocked
yeah this is not good
now you might even lose rookie 3 I think
I think rookie 3 was also a little
tricky but alright this should be good
enough okay 15 minutes left
essentially the four-game lead remains
for Geary after this game I don't know
man
a lot closer than we thought it was
gonna be yeah
and definitely some on the edge of your
seat chess here in the bullet portion
but Gary's still holding on yep
and there is still time cleared plenty
of time left to make this comeback
complete you know 15 and a half minutes
as play of time for four games of you on
a winning streak so alright so we have
an interesting decision in this game
which are passkey and I like it
I mean from a standpoint of you need to
win games it's nice for white to see
this because the king is a little bit
vulnerable with the pawn structure
compromised like that and well now
especially the launcher is very
compromised before I could even finish
my thought I look at it and you've
double isolated pawns on the F file yo B
sevens hanging now Queen takes d8 or P
so pretty that's probably been better I
mean the beach upon't still is is a
problem so real p80 played and if you
take on a two rook a to and Queen d5 I
thought it would do that too because I
thought why could get rook teaming with
tempo ooh oh I know I like this I know
though for white that's an ink yeah
exactly yeah this is there's a nice
exchange sac
chief or chief or just cement that
bishop in there loved it
so queen c4 is nice because the rook
can't attack it with the bishop covering
the see a square and mamakara is playing
extremely fast like impressively fast no
almost didn't almost like he's trying to
intimidate his opponent a little bit
well as presenting a g5 here okay I'm
just rolling right now yes it's actually
very impressive 94 is coming that h7
check of course okay so what to do now
f7 sweet why don't we just play I was
gonna say play h4 so you have threats
like Queen c4 I like that it should be
six Queen f3
oh okay yeah a little safer now
Queen comes back to f3
okay no but he's uh he is he's
maneuvering in look I know I'm so
irritated you defend everything and then
you know that a pawn over there Queen
see a check wins the Bishop on c5 I
think that's been hanging okay or not
Queen chx still wins the Bishop on c5
very founded the second time that told
me once
no but not twice before check and then
Bishop f3 and then that's sufficient
before Vicki yep Queen d7 check boom
okay
Mahmud yarv strikes back and again this
is not over
a three game lead with 13 minutes left
especially given that the momentum has
been going so aggressively in and shox
favor that now giri is again mat
strategy playing the position out makes
sense yep make sure we're updating the
players with the score but pretty sure
they must know that there's still a
chance if they're in Mahmud Arabs camp
12 minutes left twelve and a half I
don't know man I can feel it and Geary
as URIs been to overtime before right
and he's no stranger to
situation with Wesley so last year yeah
and actually I was thinking about vidit
just now because vidit said after he
lost those gaming's oven he took 30
seconds of the 5 minute portion to you
know get a break you can't do that in
Bullitt right you can't just spend
you'll waste 30 seconds in a bullet game
so it's really hard when you start going
on tilt in the bullet portion now giri
again with the white pieces going for
mom a jar of against his peers but the
the Pierce situation here looking like
there's no checkmate there's no
immediate but this has just been I don't
know weird to see shot going back to
this feels like white Queens you finally
has all the pressure what is that he
forgot my knight goes back to Genesis
that's a piece Oh No could be another
one right now
Queen what oh my old what in the world
Anish coming apart at the seams right
now this isn't this isn't role openings
this is severe Asaf and one of one of
shocks favorite weapons in rapid chess
yep and this is I mean I don't want to
say right now because only two-game lead
for gear raising look at that the
shotgun back oMG Bentley so let's see
this position is perfect for the combat
ik right it's like instead of having to
force your way to open up the position
it's just already playing it real yeah
at this point giri has got to pull it
together the momentum is is running off
the rails
that's a scary movie to play Knight to
c6 with the pen coming Queenie - Oh
Queen me what I love the time of
switching to the a file is this about to
be another win for Mom Jeff looking that
way uh nice move c16 c7 but here comes
b5 undermining the D pawn it's a c5
or maybe just yeah the effort was fun I
like that move King Ashe one just
getting out the way
yeah prophylaxis Here Come c4 at some
point open the seat I don't divorce so
good like so long I don't know why he's
waiting he inching the Queen of the C
file I loved c4 just cuz it would have
opened the D file to go with it but okay
likely Weiss attack is strong enough yes
Queen b6 knight c6 check and f6 balls
with check as well Wow and look at the
top look at mom and you're up on the
clock again this is just amazing 5000 of
you with us thanks for being here the
comeback is on for those of you who just
tuned in on each gear II was up by 7
games at one point in this match today
the biggest lead we've one of the
biggest leads we've ever had see seam go
away like this right we've seen leads
like that before but they usually stay
in that direction so a tilt tilting the
other way right now is a nice giri but
still up by one in the match with eight
and a half minutes roughly left crazy
stuff Robert did you I mean did you
think we were gonna be here we were
talking about troll openings an hour and
a half ago crazy
yep and he changed up well he didn't
change of his openings but the
appearance is good as I mentioned the
very first game of match in very quick
time controls just you know you're both
on your own and whoever's in better
shape tends to be the one scoring the
points Wow and here is resigning pretty
early and there's still eight and a half
minutes left so I don't think the early
resignations are that meaningful but
look at this position another
free-flowing position for Mahmoud Jarrah
of though actually isn't who's doing
better here this Monday for looks
great and the pani 6 is weet clearly and
rookie one just takes advantage of that
I guess you can try move like Knight to
c6 here or Knight a5 and have Queen e6
we trade trade Knight 64 yeah but I'm
just still in good shape as black though
I mean these pawns are is terrible
regardless of what happens on the
yeah I thought he was gonna take on d4
cuz c2 and f4 were both under attack and
though g4 was a good move but actually
Kingi one nice yeah look at that kim
ji-won very precise because otherwise
you've never seen was Chuck and now he
just it should be looks like it's a
drawn position right here King g2 rook
b3 Oh nope me he's okay with the pawn
being traded I guess that's alright rook
a seven maybe so if you're Deary do you
play rook takes me five and when a draw
eventually is offered you just wait
until you've like about to lose on time
and accept the drop he declined to draw
just now so he's sort of doing what I
was saying and he has no reason not to
right I mean from a match oh wait a
second g5 check if I check is pretty
devastating how did he get himself in
that spot well it's okay I'll go rook
yeah okay that also works should be good
rook b5 okay it's an H pawn so it's
funny he like almost lost well no I mean
it no I don't know that this is wrong
right he's uh he's not taking the draw
instead he's asking shock to play for
the wind I mean again this is matte
strategy that's what makes this match
format different Geary the chess player
in him wins out over the gamesman and
him and takes the draw which is you know
it's a classy thing to do but that's one
of things that makes this format
exciting is when you get in these
situations where the total clock is
against your opponent in addition to the
chess so yep and I'm sure Joshua
Chamberlain in the chat will be very
happy that mom jokes coming back because
it was critic criticizing us for
counting him out too soon but you know I
guess we were wrong to do so
mom cherubs clearly still am a match I
did not expect the bullet see it's funny
because I feel like I was misled
I usually thought that we watched mom
and your ofnot hold his own against a
much weaker opponent in bullet for too
many games before the match today yeah
exactly if I had never seen that I would
have said mom and Yara
better and bullet and mommy ever in
blitz obviously is that he's a total
monster
well Josh ambulance convinced of his
rightness but there's a reason we've
never seen comebacks past four games
ever happened so you know I'm not
exactly sure what he means that two for
two years we've been saying that matches
are over before they are but you know
he's uh he's got he he thinks he thinks
that's the case I guess so usually when
Magnus Carlson's up by 11 games you're
right we do say the match is over
so here look at this for mom and jar
once again no I agree this is this has
been the most impressive comeback we've
ever seen even if it doesn't get
completed I mean seven games down to a
situation that actually matters isn't is
amazing yep and let's see here so how
it's a black actually is a very stable
defensive setup and that's a good move
night before because now tonight takes a
to it comes the tempo but now Queen
moves away the p39 is hanging so you
don't get those smooth d5 yeah and what
it would be five nice III book takes
would be one chest it
they're both yuri missed it oh my gosh
now he's gonna get mated oh he won
anyway look at that paunch III rook b2
oh my gosh Chrissy are you good politics
f2 was actually made even easier but
this is just brutal so Geary not over
yet okay maybe now I mean if he wins
this right here this is Wow okay talk
about clutch right a game that he
absolutely had to have right there I
mean I both sides were winning in that
game at one point right yeah
and that was well I don't know if White
was winning what was better but then not
492 a2 is just with tables turn to geary
hyper terms chess pay your head chess
players really likes ourselves in theory
yep and that was a really smart
resignation by mom a job that should not
be underestimated by the way because he
said I'm just done with this I don't
want to play a rook in game where I know
I'm objectively lost know that you're
right that could have been the match if
you if you took two more minutes off and
lost anyway it would
mathematically over there it's almost
mathematically over now but it's not
quite know what's nice how long no
actually they at least have one more
game after this and if Geary does not
lose this game it should be close to
mathematically over but if Geary loses
then there's at least time for one more
game but actually well okay just babe
with the cheer thank you so much Kelly
kekel going gifted mode all right
this is this is not over yet though this
is this is a game that has to be won and
quickly mom and Europe has been playing
super fast it's like he knew for the
last half an hour that his only chance
right
Oh luli blitz out his opponent oh look
at that be to square mr. Bigsby to take
it okay it takes me to also should be
fun but I mean it's just really enough
nighty for white I mean sorry for black
I don't know I mean the Kings not
kidding
yeah I mean it well he's the c-4 square
for his King so that at least his son
right but okay take a 7 look at Gary
trying to create the net I thought maybe
he was trying to walk the King up to d3
wow this is a weird position it's a 93
checked forcing another trade to play a
5 ok nice dude I guess the stars rook t5
check oh he knew 100 ok this is it yeah
okay he has to win this game you can't
afford to repeat if he does two game is
not enough time to game deficit two
minutes on the clock
uh-oh the only way the only way there's
enough time is if he wins this next
scene oh really
he just grimaced he kind of knows his
manager probably told him but he's he
has to win this game quickly it's it's
literally winner go home right now and
here comes the Frankenstein Dracula not
quite okay almost miss yeah beer
Stanley reverse Spanish very sadly it's
a mean of oh man
okay d5 this is looking from at least
from a you know a classical standpoint
this looks very pleasant for black
wow that was this has been a really a
real treat today given the Dominus we
saw earlier and then the type of
comeback that has been staged by Mahmoud
yar of regardless of the fact that you
know at this point he may not win but
but this has been a really really
incredible match honestly all things
considered and look at the chess mug
being bought there by both tattered
green earlier and gets we appreciate
that remember everything bought today
and the merch store goes directly to the
players as far as the funds go we love
you - Joshua thanks for being a sub I
appreciate criticism definitely I think
it I think it's hard to not call games
being over and then if people blunder to
be criticized for why the game didn't
finish that way but you know okay you
know Danny you're just trying to be the
guy who is the and every single I know
he has been a Gary has been in two of
our favorite matches of all time right
Wesley so and now shock shock rearm of
Gaurav and this time he's actually
moving on yep
and here with the black pieces okay Gary
again is well how many pawns was white
his upper part I thought black was up
upon because the attack was coming but
nope Wow Queen a fight nice move well
well well
so take on a five nine to five bishop g6
then 97 check that's not good so alright
the match the time is officially up and
winning this game is what's the math on
that like sixty bucks it's worth it it's
worth something right given that every
game is worth something now being
defensive at all
love you guys I just like people to know
yeah we do we try hard we hear
everything and we do our best
so anyway 6000 of you with us right now
you almost witnessed the greatest
comeback of all time but hopefully
you'll stick around for the interviews
because this was still one of the
greatest matches we've ever had
and probably shock finishes on a high
note looks like white is better here
maybe yep maybe yeah
well it's over now rook takes c5 what's
going on there
was that a free pawn yeah but he's got
two of them now right breasts answer c5
you got played rook takes e4 well I
guess beef I was coming down afterwards
I'm very confused what's been happening
here okay I'm sure about your players
ill ooh there's a little little strange
okay it's official onigiri is moving on
the only thing excuse me the only we
don't know is what the final score will
be depending on this game but looks like
it'll be about a two-game victory given
the likely result here is a peaceful one
all of you that are with us sticking
around we're gonna talk to the players
we got questions for them and I wonder
if they know that the time is up I think
they do they've both been very attentive
to the chat today and I think they know
gosh it's doing this for the fans free
Chester yes is it just always free
almost right as far as watching chess
goes so yeah but I mean like you know in
basketball you pay for the ticket but
overtime is free because right you know
overtime
how many games did it finished they
played a lot of game
16 a half 14 and a half yeah this will
be this is the thirty-second yes it
looks like it's this one of the one of
the longest max we've ever had maybe the
second longest in history so yeah I
really want to know if either player
knew that that was called the Brooklyn
variation of the L Jochen does it really
matter no well what does really matter
is we just had one of the most exciting
matches we've ever had the players are
with us now and we are gonna bring them
into our into our call and thank them
both for being here
Anish and shot can you guys hear us
uh-huh Anish Anish can you hear us he's
working on it
well shucks um I know I know the match
didn't didn't finish the way you wanted
it to but it was an incredibly exciting
comeback and we had had us on the edge
of our seats we thought that we thought
that you might you might finish it there
for a moment what was going through your
head as as you were struggling earlier
in the match and you lost a few in a row
you started playing some pretty wild
openings what was your what was your
match strategy there what was your
thought of course it's very interesting
months and they just play some openings
I know is I hope it's better than my
openings I guess I just play some
interesting I think it's I play just for
fun and the night is where interest so I
was very happy to play as much very nice
thanks for a punch well thank you for
being amazing here you uh you Anish
we'll ask you after having a big lead
one of the biggest leads we've ever seen
get down to that small whoa what was the
point where you were you were starting
to get nervous there and and and feeling
feeling like okay I need to stop I need
to put it into this well I mean I'm
playing shock react you know it's not a
surprise district here I can be two
games in a row so I was never shocked I
expected it to be a tough match I mean
at some point clearly I was in a roll
and sharpey I was completely down ok
it's a long matches three hours for
online matches very very long time and I
never played that long matches normal
speaking and I know that there is some
sort of a rule when I play online with
some weaker player that okay which is
nothing to do with today's match but in
general like any match that I play even
if someone starts with a big lead
towards the end of the match you kind of
even out somehow you know no matter no
matter the strength and today's
obviously I played the opponent who is
the very least equal to me even stronger
place player but
even when I play weaker players online I
mean I can beat them 4-0 and the moment
I get carried away playing too many
games you know the longer it goes on the
more you even out and the same with
difficult opponents I think it's hard to
get a grip on someone and keep it to the
end but I'm very happy actually did I
manage to rain again because it got
really close indeed wait you've been
apart or two of our closest and most
exciting matches ever this this year
you're on the the winning side of it
you'll be moving on to face Levon
Aronian of real quick thoughts on on how
you see your match up there with with
Levon and and what what you well it was
quite funny I
I don't watch all the matches I mean I'm
busy person as well although the matches
are really exciting and but I wasn't
able to watch all the matches but this
match until I won I was able to with
just one minute so I click on the thing
and turnout they already over and then I
say interview of Levon and he says well
you know I'm not I mean we were you
asked him actually whether he is going
to who he expects to face and he says as
well I mean Anisha is my boy but of
course shock we are going to win the
match easily is going to be my opponent
and I thought okay one minute of the
whole broadcast just get trash trashed
me I mean other people so I'm very happy
first of all to prove to the one that I
can and I okay only one is most
difficult opponent for me since I
managed to come back and guess valley
mechanic recently I've so far never
managed to come back against LaVon is a
very bad opponent for me but I think
these three hours are going to be a good
opportunity for me to get to know him
better and perhaps maybe if not if not
in that match maybe in the future to be
able to you know to get to know him a
bit little closer as a player because on
my mesh with Wesley it was incredible
how much inside gave me to this its
strengths weaknesses and I think I hope
for the same with Levon head has anybody
ever told you you are the best interview
in chess you know that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're making my day here shock shock I
know you've been your so you've been
such a gracious obviously runner up the
batch was super close I don't even know
what else to ask besides we hope you
come back next year even though we know
it didn't go your way this year and um
do you any other final thoughts who do
you see as the favorite when when LaVon
takes on Anish were you taken okay I
just want to see is interesting much and
I think it approval interesting my said
I don't want to say who and why
but I just want to seem a bit much
well I got no more questions Robert it's
your stage I have a classic question
it's also I was shocked
are there any more openings that you
wanted to play but didn't get a chance
to because it seemed like you're willing
to play anything yeah no but the guy
everybody listen Oliver it's incredible
the most difficult move for me was h3 I
guess H I don't know I just try to play
some interest in she's very lost and now
he's back though we said that after h3
went well for him and then I think the
next game was d4 Knight c6 and we said
what would we said well he got a good
position with h3 so maybe he'll get a
good position with d4 knight c6 but he
didn't but Danny what happened was we
saw the position after move Tanner like
oh that's pretty good for white and I
said Danny do you realize this game
started with one age three we didn't
even realize that it started like that
but but it's not so easy because you
know well you know after h3 you got to
think you know you are white but here's
this H extra move h3 it's difficult it's
difficult to find a way Anisha the fans
really wanted to know will you listen to
Van Halen and Afrojack or what were you
listening to what music no no no not at
well to be honest I it's nothing really
spectacular is the regular pop music
that is going on the radio and you know
the amongst the favorites today I think
we're the Nicki Minaj and
and the famous batch rapper who actually
I had the opportunity to visit a concert
of eleven okay so we have we have a time
marker on each said who he was listening
to at 1:24 p.m. Pacific so I'll do it
cuz we were giving away a one-year
Diamond membership if anyone was able to
guess your music during the match I I
saw on Twitter in one of the breaks that
somebody guess that I listened to that
rubber but I don't know whether he gets
it from the from the vibe that was here
in this room or whether she guessed it
because I had previously mentioned that
rapper um Tanaka so okay well we'll find
out we're gonna review that and get that
guy diamond membership if he's out it so
um well you're but you've both been
great this has been honestly especially
with the interview get this has been my
favorite match of the year so far thank
you both for being so fantastic thank
you and I wish we wish you both the best
of luck and on each we'll see you in the
next round see you right okay well
Robert we it's just me and you know how
hope is obviously I know somebody's
gonna clip that no I mean his comments
about the competition and the chess
interview is not being very strong I
mean it was that not the most amazing
but the most fun we've had an interview
like ever in our three years of doing
this yeah that was phenomenal I love it
you know it's good to show some
personality and it's just great because
chess players you're playing silence
your entire games you don't really to
see a person's actual you know what
they're like you see that their play is
like and to so here any age I know India
I know that he's trash talk to me since
the first moment I met him so I assumed
that next time I speak to him I'm gonna
get some beef from him but you know it's
great to see you nice being able to talk
like that and you know he's a he freely
speaks his mind it's cool
ya know they were both great honestly
this was this was so much fun oh man
sorry lots of messages coming in now
that things are wrapping up but there
you have it everybody that is what
happened in round 1 a great way to bring
this thing to a close seems like we
saved the best for last
inadvertently and onigiri barely holds
on he will move on to face Levon Aronian
despite or onehans comments and I can't
wait we don't know exactly who will be
up first but police stay tuned many of
these guys are going to be in st. Louis
at the 960 championship we have the
Olympia coming up so we're doing
everything we can to work around the
schedules of these amazing top players
and hopefully you'll see more guys like
Maxime and and others streaming very
soon on on Twitch I don't even know what
else to say it really had great time
today Robert we'll see you in round 2
everyone thanks for being here and good
night or a good morning or good
afternoon depending on where you are
bye everyone